foreign
all right good morning so we're going to
hear from the Department of Corrections
the commissioner is here along with
staff and if you'd like to introduce
your folks
yes
the public do you want me to do it again
[Laughter]
that's all right
I have this uh so for the record with me
in the room is my deputy director of
administration Lisa Stone and our
strategic Communications and legislative
liaison uh Jane Graham to my right is
our director of administration John
Hansen and for the record I'm Helen
Hanks the commissioner of the Department
of Corrections
welcome thank you
thank you the uh
the committee is a packet which is
intended to give you literally an agency
overview in the highest level I could
contemplate as well as a second document
which should be no surprise that the
agency has been aggressively at working
on our Recruitment and Retention efforts
because Staffing is our most critical
resource
on the second page of the larger handout
that has our logo on it
defines our mission as well as our
statute that creates the department I
know you will read it and enjoy those
references but in short we provide safe
secure Humane supervision and
evidence-based Rehabilitation to enhance
Public Safety in the state of New
Hampshire
on page two I give an overview of the
three Correctional Facilities that we
have what our current population is at
those facilities and then on the bottom
of the page a citation to the secure
psychiatric unit and the separate unit
within that unit the residential
treatment unit
I'll point out the population the spu is
I'll call flip-flopped
um where we have more civilly committed
than sentenced individuals but that
number does adjust
um and has had no uh trended pattern to
it if you will over the time that I've
on the third page
we have one transitional work center
um
off okay let me explain that we have one
transitional work center for men that is
not behind the secure perimeter that is
different for women when the women's
prison facility was built their
transitional work center is within the
secure perimeter of that facility on the
same grounds as the New Hampshire state
prison for men
we have three transitional housing units
again indicates where they are in the
on page four
we list our 11 probation and parole
district offices and the current
supervision caseload for those offices
we have as of today
362 people that are in fugitive status
that have absconded from their
supervision
and within the division of field
services we also have a central office
as we refer to it that is a Collections
Unit and collects fines and obligations
on behalf of the sentencings sentencing
documents as well as the obligations
they create through destruction of state
property during incarceration on average
that unit collects approximately two
million dollars a year
we have three other uh we'll reference
facilities our headquarters facility is
a few floors and a building owned and
managed uh by Health and Human Services
as well as administrative Services we
have a warehouse and we have our
commission I have just a quick question
question we've had a number of hearings
on the sununu center and what's going to
be done with it which should be done
with it
um a number of us I'm sure you've been
down there to the more modern secure
unit which is you know again relatively
you know is is any of that space
something you could use instead of at
the stage just abandoning that facility
like I'm I was looking at your secure
psychiatric unit with the sununu center
work for you there or or some other
facility just it seems like a a very
nice the the modern part of the facility
seems like something that certainly
could be used by Corrections represent
leishman that's a great question we were
asked that question pre the design and
build of the women's prison we went down
and that was my opportunity to see that
space
um we opted that that was not going to
be suitable space for adults in a
correctional environment and as it
pertains to the secure psychiatric unit
my apprehension at this point giving our
staffing and resources to create another
geographically disparate location and
try to staff that with all of the
disciplines we need to run nursing staff
mental health staff security staff so on
and so forth would just increase the
challenges the Department's facing at
this point all right thanks thank you
thank you Mr chairman so related to that
wouldn't aren't there current staff at
at the youth center that might be let go
when it's closed that could be usable in
your organization represent McGuire I'm
not sure I know that their census is
very small and that facility would house
a lot larger of a population and if we
were going to use it the population
would be significantly larger I don't
know the cadrea staff they have down
there but if it's for a smaller
population I would have to times that by
possibly six
but I appreciate that further question
thank you any for where we have a little
break any action
thank you on page five um I start to I
want I want to provide you some basic
what I would call demographics in a
broad sense of that term
when people come into our facility they
self-report their race this is the
collection of that information the state
of New Hampshire predominantly
incarcerates white uh individuals
um you'll see their self-reported
breakouts
on page six oh yeah so the the yellow
pie is missing a number
it is squashed we'll fix that for you
[Laughter]
yeah because there's a different point
board
on page six we also uh predominantly
incarcerate uh biological males at the
rate of 93 percent and seven percent of
our population are women as of today
just to give you a numerical reflection
that does not include the women at Shea
Farm in that number that is 120 for
women in the New Hampshire correctional
facility for women
on page seven
with that statistics knowing that 120 of
these individuals on page seven in this
Adrian or age range are women we wanted
to show you that most of the people
incarcerated are between the ages of 30
so why is that it's
that's a great question
I would share with you a lot of the
research says that as individuals who
have been impacted or involved in the
justice system as they get over the age
of 45 they essentially start to I'll say
mature in a basic sense and age out of
the system and truly want to change
their pattern of behaviors we have a lot
of impulsivity in the corrections
population Justice involved in these age
ranges
um it's also interesting to point out to
you because you'll often hear people say
that the corrections uh department has a
lot of aged individuals and what I would
share with you is it's not their age it
is their lifestyle choices that have
adversely affected their health care and
their health outcomes so you'll see this
yes between the ages of 50 and over 60
we have a larger pup we have a large
population but it is not the largest
population of people incarcerated and um
I'll I'll share with you in a an
additional slide when opioid use
disorder and substance use disorder in
general is one of the primary diseases
that we're treating in incarceration
including IV drug use all of those
things then blend into other public
health issues including hepatitis C HIV
and other deteriorations of the human
body so we're dealing with a very ill
group of individuals medically ill and
that's obviously why our medical
expenses are as high as they are
um do you segregate the population by
age keep them together when there's
similar ages representative McGuire no
the way individuals are triaged is by
what's called a classification system
and that classification system is
outlined in our state administrative
rule if you want to dive into that
further but in simple terms we examine
their crime we examine the information
that we know about their actions during
their crime to assess for levels of
violence and things of that nature we
assess their mental health needs their
medical needs and Frailty as well as
other elements common across Corrections
and then we create class classification
scores and that is the determination of
their housing so it's not it's not just
primarily their age
we have as an organization definitely
I've been before the legislature and at
one time we had enough individuals who
were aged but also medically informed
that we even contemplated do we try to
take over a space up at glencliffe but
that's changed significantly since then
we've really leveraged obviously our
medical parole statute but the numbers
and how we provide care and Corrections
has changed in advanced and quite
frankly our Health Care staff do one
heck of a job providing Health Care
during someone's incarceration
I apologize that I keep clearing my
throat but that cold air definitely
triggered something in my lungs
on page eight we do a Breakout by crime
type these are high level
um categorical descriptions that
Correctional agencies compare across
States so that names might not be
indicative of what they are there are
some that are very clear alcohol related
drug-related drugs and alcohol related
but underneath that large paragraph what
you'll see is the term personal means a
crime associated with violence that
means the crime involved a bodily damage
to a person the majority of our male
population are incarcerated for felonies
under the crime statute of aggravated
felony sexual assault and felony sexual
assault in the state of New Hampshire so
our smaller population
are people who have become incarcerated
for possession of
um and violations of the controlled Drug
Act
are there any questions on page eight
on page nine I think it's important to
share with you that luckily for this
department who has a staffing issue that
our population has gone down absent that
population reduction I could not be
sitting here before you achieving the
mission we have today and we still are
struggling with the Staffing deficit but
it also shows you that our staffing
excuse me our population decline was not
the result of covid-19 which is what
other Corrections agencies across the
country have identified ours is because
our state implemented things like Drug
Court mental health court veterans court
and really looked further down the
criminal justice
intercepts if you will and try to
appropriately divert people from
incarceration if it was safe for Public
Safety and I think the state of New
Hampshire should be proud of the support
they've provided for those type of
interventions and this graphic
definitely demonstrates that
so I guess I'd like to back up just a
little bit you mentioned drugs now
obviously it's been a huge debate in the
legislature about marijuana
do you have a number of people
incarcerated for marijuana crimes
representative Leachman my favorite
question my favorite question because
I've been asked it now for the last
three years we have one person whose
sole charge is for possession and
distribution of marijuana from the 1980s
but that individual had such a
significant quantity that they were
trying to push through the U.S Postal
Service that I'm not even sure why
they're in our custody not in federal
custody but other than that the state of
New Hampshire is really only from our
Vantage Point based on the controlled
Drug Act crimes we have incarcerated
focusing on opioid fentanyl
methamphetamines cocaine those
significant
charges if I have I think I I have maybe
two or three people who are incarcerated
with possession of cannabis charges but
they have other charges associated with
again cocaine fentanyl much more
significantly tangible exposure outcome
being death
interesting thanks yes yes sure
representative McGuire thank you so I
missed when you you mentioned what what
to what do you attribute this large
decline of The Last Five Years thank you
representative McGuire it is the state's
support of entity um of interventions
such as Drug Court mental health court
veterans court really uh rebuilding our
mental health system and not looking at
this is not meant to say that the
legislature have done this but
Corrections had become really the last
Mental Health Resource when the mental
health system had been deterior
deteriorated now we're seeing and have
been seeing a lot more opportunity if
it's again appropriate for Public Safety
to divert people from incarceration even
the use of probation is a is an
opportunity to divert from incarceration
but really the wide implementation of
drug court The increased implementation
of mental health court and other
specialty courts that recognize the
correlation between some criminal acts
and a mental health disorder or trauma
from serving as a veteran have been
smart and wise choices the state has
made
College yeah so what you're saying is
the the number of crimes committed at
the beginning is roughly is maybe the
same but they're getting some of some of
the criminals are getting diverted into
other kinds of programs before they wind
up with you is that is that right I
would not affirm that the number of
crimes have gone up or decreased I'm
telling you that I definitely know that
many are being diverted and what that
many is I I don't know what the base
number is okay so we don't really know
if if the origin of of crime is up or
down or whatever yeah well we know that
um as a state we've been ranked uh
number one for the last several years
for uh our safety and our correction
system based on Publications from U.S
news who does do a review of States we
should be very proud of that the crime
rate I think we actually scored an A or
a plus something to that effect uh at
least last year and I think we all
continue to watch I think it's also the
level of crime you have to monitor
because certainly violent crime compared
to other again those crime categories
make it all make your question very
challenging for me to try to answer
right now thank you yeah
representative evil or Griffin any
for all
on the women's prison we were over in
public works I we really appreciated the
extent to which legislators were
included in the process and my question
and I'm not sure when to ask it I just
remember when we were talking about the
women's prison one of the big focuses
was the programming that was available
to women and to make sure that it was at
least parallel to what the men had for
opportunities and also to give them a
more centralized place so you could
provide those opportunities and I just
wondered how that was going
anything that you could shed light on
has it really benefited the women that
are there
that's a and first I appreciate your
support and other members of the
legislation support and seeing that
project to where it is today and the
additional support for the funding to
create a Vocational Center that was not
we were not able to fund in the initial
build I will sneak peek preview let you
know that based on the apologize but I
call it covet economics at the time that
amount is now not enough and we'll come
back in our capital budget projects list
to ask for an additional appropriation
to see that to its fruition now in the
existing infrastructure of the building
we have advanced a lot of that area and
we continue to work with New Hampshire
legal assistance in a collaborative
effort to avoid any litigation to
identify the programs and interventions
that we've engaged in really on the
vocational side
I do have a slide in here that I think
also helps answer that question across
the whole agency but we do have some
more work on the women's side to do and
that build and that building will help
us attain it but there are a lot of
different unique opportunities we're
delivering there and I'll just highlight
at least one we implemented What's
called the pathways program and that
program is a combination of called the
multifaceted areas of life whether it's
your mental health your physical
wellness your vocational opportunities
your educational opportunities we
created a modified therapeutic
environment and we layered over a
program called the if project
where we paid for and partnered with a
group to come in and teach journaling to
help women in many instances forgive
themselves first because many have not
done that and then to move forward and
figure out how to then develop a life
path that is free from the justice
system post their release and many of
the women also are now giving back by
attending Juvenile Diversion sessions
and talking about their stories with the
hope that it will help impact juveniles
just starting out touching the justice
system so they do not end up having a
life of incarceration
thanks you're welcome
represent Griffin
commissioner I know years ago when we
were looking at the design of the
women's prison a lot of legislatures had
concern about uh
the number of uh
guides that it took
because of the physical layout of the
building they they anticipated that the
number of personnel would be higher than
might otherwise be the case as that
turned out to be the case and if so how
have you solved that problem
thank you for that question
representative Griffin and I I remember
those days and I've remembered that
there were 11 a designs that were being
conceptualized and uh with the support
of director Hanson and myself in
different roles at the time we brought
it all back into what I would call scope
um instead of Designing and building a
campus style uh building we brought it
into a central building we moved into
that building in 2018 knowing we did not
have enough Corrections Officers in the
capacity and it was going to evoke the
use of overtime the unfortunate story is
that status has not changed so even with
the authorized number we have not been
able to hire to that authorized number I
think the design makes sense and what we
asked for makes sense I think the
challenge we continue to face is having
people understand what choosing a career
in Corrections is and I also have a
slide to show you that financially why
we have not overcome that barrier as far
as our base pay so the agency is still
costing the state significant amounts of
overtime for that we apologize but in
the same regard we don't because we're
achieving that mission with even fewer
staff today than we did the last budget
cycle and I'm proud of the team for
accomplishing that
thank you for that answer thank you
not to wander too far away from your
presentation but uh I'm here for you sir
representative evil touched on something
and thank you for bringing the
legislature into the process and
oversight of the
construction of a woman's prison I guess
is the best way of saying it you also
must have used what Das and other
agencies because you know to be quite
Keen we're looking at a parking garage
and kind of there's some debate about
oversight so you had your own Personnel
Das any other suggestions that you might
offer us to
the oversight of such a project that's a
great question for director Hansen
so as representative people and some of
the others here remember
so during the women's prison project we
followed the state law which requires us
to use administrative Services Public
Works division to help us oversee that
process we did something very unique
it's the first and possibly the last
construction manager risk project when
we did the women's prison so we
basically acted the owning agency acted
like the owner of a piece of property
and you're going to sub out the
foundation work the drainage the framing
and we scoped everything so that was
very unique
we did save money that way we did not
based on square footage costs have quite
enough money to do everything we needed
so we spent an inordinate amount of time
as some remember doing uh value
engineering because at first we went in
saying okay we can build it but we can't
build the gymnasium we can build it but
we can't do the ball field so let's
let's do our job costing in such a way
and as as the commissioner pointed out
we ended up building phase or design 11a
by taking two feet off the front of the
building which has shortened everything
up and it worked based on the the about
500 a square foot Costa so getting back
to your question though representative
leishman Das was a great partner in that
project we had actually a new person
come on board a very talented architect
um named Tim Smith who worked with us we
were locked at the hip for a couple
years and uh so that did work out very
well for us all right thanks that's I
figured that might stimulate a question
chance buildings that uh you weren't
exactly sure where you even going to
build it to start with because I
remember it was lawsuit related and the
money was put into the budget and
uh
so I appreciate again the involvement
that we had and and um and we toured it
and it was really exciting but I
actually have another question on The
Vocational Center so the uh is that a
place where you're going to try to start
consolidating the vocational programs
for the men and the women like in one
building or step well no I mean in in
Cycles
we will it's just for women it's just
for women just for women thank you for
the mild heart attack
um we will not be having incarcerated
men come into the incarcerated women's
facility but we need a separate facility
on the grounds and within the secure
perimeter of the New Hampshire
correctional facility for women to make
sure we have what I would call a robust
skill Development building so that
traditionally that had been
non-traditional occupations can be
provided so that women can go out and
fill the voids in our our communities in
areas of manufacturing and other trades
it's really to help have a robust trades
type school that starts the process and
we've done a lot of things within this
square footage of what we have we have a
manufacturing program more like an
Amazon style skill set we have a
sublimation program where you put the
images on everything you could imagine
and allow people to learn design and
marketing we have and it
yep we have commercial driver's license
program an opportunity for women to
attain their CDL and have done some
Partnerships on how to move that forward
even more successfully with the DMV and
Dot when we have our state agency
Partnerships we've released individuals
from our facilities to state employment
jobs and that's been a wonderful success
in many instances but we really
understand we need to have a physical
space to do more on the women's prison
side
I just have one other follow-up so of
course part of the idea there is to help
these women live successful lives
outside of the prison system right have
you seen
um success and in recidivism issue you
know that sort of thing that's a great
question uh and not directly related to
vocation and employment skilled building
but in 2018 I took the opportunity to
request from our partner agency Health
and Human Services application of funds
under the state opioid response dollars
implementing what we piloted at that
point point called re-entry care
coordination and also harm reduction
principles for people with opioid use
disorder which is voluntarily at time of
release we offer people naloxone and
then the re-entry care coordination is
assertive case management 12 months
post-release that one pilot with women
we started with women demonstrated that
we helped women navigate through through
life's challenges Post Release from
incarceration and reduce their
recidivism rate in the first 12 months
that proving concept we then asked in
2019 to add two for men and continued to
demonstrate its success then this magic
year 2020 came along
and 2021 and it created some hiccups in
the flow of that funding so we have had
a hard time retaining those Grant funded
positions and have actually asked in the
budget process that those become
full-time positions because it is
definitely an effective tool to help
people Post Release which is one of
those most stressful times in that first
12 months to navigate things I don't
know about all of you but I know when I
have an issue with my health care and
I'm a very resilient person there are a
lot of phone calls that you can have to
make now put that same small scenario in
the hands of somebody who's overcome a
lot of those challenges this person is
meant to be the partner for that whether
it's Child Care Resources connectivity
to a primary care provider which is
almost impossible these days in other
elements so that is a an answer I will
provide you with regard to impacting
recidivism absent having that trades
program
you're welcome
thank you so on page 10
um again some more statistics what we
provide for you here is the population
by maximum sentence what's important in
this data is I am not able to calculate
those with consecutive sense that means
a sentence that they will serve
post-completion of what the sentence
they're in and they can sometimes be
paroled into that consecutive sentence
so there's no predictability of when
they'll be granted that opportunity to
Parole in there so it is a
straightforward statistic of the
sentences people are in now their
maximum sentence structure so you'll see
that the area of between five and ten
years and 10 and 20 is indicative of
that graphic where I show you the
highest percentage of people
incarcerated or in for violent crimes
foreign
McGuire thank you so why is the total on
this page different from the total for
2021 on the other page very intuitive
and smart question representative
McGuire because this number includes uh
approximately 200 plus individuals that
we have housed out of state and we
maintain about an average of that number
every year
the other numbers are physical
population and those that we're managing
in our care and custody in our New
Hampshire facilities so let me ask about
that so aren't the out-of-state ones a
trade you give them one of ours and take
one of theirs kind of thing or is it not
usually we don't always trade equitably
usually and in some of those trades
we're actually trading and helping
support people on parole through the
interstate compact process but we do owe
some states some and some States owe us
some so it's a it's a distribution
system that's not as a perfect art of
intent
so uh yeah may I follow up so so are you
saying we have
an extra 200 from out of state or no
you're saying an hour 200 or somewhere
else yes
okay all right thank you and those are
almost always related to protective
custody issues or uh the amount of
violent conduct they've engaged and they
need to be in a bigger
organization the larger Correctional
Facility yeah so when this was explained
to me years ago they said when you have
a gang who commits a crime you want to
put one member of the gang in each div
in different prisons you don't have to
put them together and that's why some go
out of state does that that's a great
example yeah
thank you
any other questions on page 10.
all right
challenges
page 11 is to highlight our challenges
um
our challenges increase significantly in
uh 2022 and that was post I would call
it a decline of the height of the
covid-19 pandemic we had a significant
number of our employees choose to retire
deservedly they were quite frankly
exhausted and had given you know greater
than 20 usually greater than 25 years so
you'll see that blue hashed column that
is pointing downward that number
negative 44. so when you look at the
previous trended line
we started to see a high level of
we track it this way because we want to
see the bar graph go above the zero line
and you can see that in 2023 we've
recruited to date 22 new Corrections
Officers
we're still challenged I was very proud
of us for still recruiting 34 in 2022
because recruiting during covid was very
difficult but when we were already
behind in our staffing Recruitment and
challenged with recruiting this did not
help this agency and hence why we did at
least on two occasions with the support
of the governor have the National Guard
um there are other positions within the
agency that may be smaller in number but
their resource is significant and those
are our chefs our plumbers our
electricians and they've had varying
rates of vacancy between 30 and 50
percent
the corrections officer vacancy right
now across the whole organization is 50
that's the highest I've ever seen it and
we are constantly monitoring what we're
doing and how we're doing business to
make sure we're running a safe
environment
one of the challenges we experience as
an agency trying to attract new
employees is quite frankly the Hampshire
state prison for men our largest
facility built in 1878.
yes ma'am
um It's A Hard Sell to sell that
facility to people entering law
enforcement in their beginning of their
career because they interview
requirements to be a corrections officer
and I'm not advocating to reduce those
requirements are the same as a community
police officer are now essentially the
same as becoming a new state trooper and
try to sell being in New Hampshire
communities in a lovely new car and
engaging in public safety and I'll use
myself maybe pulling me over and saying
slow down versus come work in the New
Hampshire state prison for men where in
our reception and diagnostic area you're
you're one the lever away from not being
able to open the doors you have no as a
staff person no control over your HVAC
in the summer it's as hot in your area
as it is where the residents live and
I'm not saying it should be
disproportionate but the reality and
what I have heard a lot is these people
are incarcerated well the Corrections
Officers are not incarcerated and we
should be running a Humane Correctional
institution and until we can create an
environment that Fosters a healthy
environment for our staff and as well as
those we put into custody we're going to
continue to have challenges especially
given that's our largest facility so you
will see on our capital budget request
approximately two and a half million
dollars asking to design and find a
conceptual Financial path through the
state of New Hampshire to build a new
correctional facility for men
I go into further detail on those fiscal
plant challenges on another slide and
quite frankly we built the North Country
facility in 2000 so we will need to be
mindful to keep that infrastructure
stable so we're not you know decades
from now in the same place because the
approximate cost was 350 million dollars
for a new prison and coveted economics
that number is no longer the same number
it's closer to 500 million dollars
we and I have appreciated the support
because it is a recognition of this
legislature's knowledge of the
infrastructure challenges of
approximately 10 million 12 million
dollars in capital budget Appropriations
I'm a basic homeowner that sort of
sounds like a mortgage payment for me
and a better investment so I just put
that out for your awareness and can I
answer any questions representative
hatch
thank you commissioner and um
the North Country facility and the
concrete facility is the uh vacancy rate
for employees that is uh the same or how
much of an interchange is there between
the two prisons to address that or is
there representative that's a great
question and I will talk about some of
recruitment strategies we piloted up
there they're in a slightly better place
but it is not where it should be I won't
give you specific vacancy rates by site
because that is a safety risk for my
institutions but it's an intuitive
question and I'll explain in another
page okay why they're in a slightly
better place I'm sorry to Jump Ahead
thank you no chair you you're welcome to
do it representative McGuire thank you
um The Gray Line here what is that that
line is referred to as termed they've
terminated their employment with us or
we've terminated their employment with
us and so what we've been studying for
several years now is for someone who is
making the choice to leave why are they
leaving they're leaving in many
instances because they're being
recruited by other law enforcement
departments including the liquor the
Sheriff's Department the community
police departments and that's one
primary recruitment path the other is
because of the fiscal plant and the
inordinate overtime so that bar we also
need that to decrease and the
recruitment number to increase so that
it equalizes itself
yeah so I assume the the um the retirees
are somewhere approximately 20 years
maybe a little more right right
um do you have an average for the termed
how many how long they stay
yeah we found that if we can get someone
to stay greater than three years they
generally stay they're leaving within
the first and third year in that column
on the following page I think it's
important to describe the corrections
officer's job because it is a
significant job we are asking people to
do it is a powerful Mission but it is
literally
um an understated job we ask individuals
to go into a Corrections Facility to
work with pre-identified people with
felonies
they have felonies they are not
Community citizens my Correctional force
my Correctional law enforcement group
handcuffs people more literally more
than our community law enforcement
indicative of the environment that
they're in and the stress that they are
under to be hyper Vigilant every day all
day is real and tangible and so I
provided some hyperlinks because I think
that is an important piece of
information that has never truly been
imparted up to our legislative members
and in fact the life expectancy of a
corrections officer is 59 years old
compared to the national average of 75.
yep
so that is why it is so important to
have functional
Correctional Facilities that are
responsive to the staff that we're
bringing in there because they're rising
to the occasion and I will also share
with you and it is not a a dig on
anything anyone has said but to refer to
a corrections officer as a guard is is a
term we have to extinguish it gone are
the days that we're just walking through
and Counting people they are literally
Corrections Officers because they're
engaged 24 hours a day and correcting
and mentoring people whose patterns in
life are not healthy and so I would
impart if you could pass that education
on we would greatly appreciate it they
are professionals and they do a one heck
of a job on behalf of the State of New
Hampshire
and I hope that that number changed I
would also share with you as an
opportunity we've done a lot now that
we're out of the protect against the
invisible enemy covid-19 to move forward
initiatives around our employee health
and wellness program so we've got to
have our first Comfort dog operator we
have a family service organization a non
a non-profit that's been formed we've
created employee spaces within our
Correctional Facilities that don't look
like they're in a correctional facility
that give them a place of calm where
they can go and decompress laugh if you
will we're doing a lot of things
I provided in a more colorful packet
separate packet a list of every
Recruitment and Retention effort we've
engaged in and two of the most important
things we did was create a recruitment
and retention Committee in our North
Country representative hatch that'll
help explain your question earlier and
one in our Southern Tier and that's a
mix of not just our corrections officer
but all the other Corrections
professionals it takes for us to run a
community set of services in a
correctional facility and we're building
off of their ideas and one of those
ideas that first started at the North
country was to partner any applicant
especially in the corrections officer
field with another corrections officer
so that they can communicate through
that law enforcement background check
that that takes the time it takes and
also keep them engaged and that's worked
incredibly well so that's why the North
country is slightly ahead we've
implemented that in our Southern
Recruitment and Retention committee and
the leaders on that committee on the
security Rank and file have already put
10 new people through the physical
training process and that's really
working so we're hoping to see that tide
change here across the whole
organization
so I share that with you because it's a
pretty robust packet that you have you
can see we've tried to leave no stone
unturned and as you go through it if you
have ideas please share them back with
the organization we really appreciate
everyone's involvement in helping us to
find a solution
were there questions on the page that I
gave the references to on page 12 before
I guess the statistics are kind of
shocking 59 years versus 75 years as far
as life expectancy now you mentioned
your Capital request as far as getting
the process going for a new Men's prison
that's obviously going to take some time
but in the short term if you were you
know Queen for the day or what would you
do to make things better if you had
anything one thing that you could do to
for retention making things better for
the officers Corrections Officers
that's a x a question I appreciate the
intent in which it was asked
I know that the there's a sunset on the
state's ability to recruit and create
retention incentives on June 30th of
2023 I would suggest that that not
Sunset I would also suggest that as a
state agency and as a state I understand
the historical civil role we all play
but it is hard to compete with private
organizations
in trying to recognize our employees I'm
not allowed to use State dollars I'm not
allowed to throw a barbecue I'm not
allowed to do the simple thank yous that
our Corrections team needs and I'll give
you a great example even if the first
week of May if you don't know it every
year the first full week of May is
Corrections Officers and now Corrections
professional week that week is always
funded out of the pockets of my
leadership which again we do it without
complaint we want to support our team
our unions step up but no State funds
can be used to say thank you I really
believe that has to change something
reasonable it can just be that one week
would say a lot to the corrections
professional with regard to the
infrastructure and investment that the
legislature has made we have to continue
to invest in the fiscal plan
one of the projects funded through the
arpa opportunities is going to actually
finally resolve the HVAC system in two
of our largest general population units
the medium custody north and south and
that will actually create equalized air
conditioning and airflow during the hot
and cold months and that that benefits
our staff so those small things make a
difference
investing in our training budget our
actual Fleet budget all of those things
make a difference we have I would say
under asked in the last decade for our
training resources and the budget I put
forward this year asks for what we need
to develop our employees and to get our
physical items in a place that we're not
saying do we use this expired stab
resistant vest because we don't have
enough money to buy a new one that
sounds like the most absurd question
someone's ever asked me no we buy a new
one because the safety of our staff
should be the first and most important
thing at the end of the day
so I have a question going back to not
being able to hold it like a cookout or
something I know other agencies and
departments
do have do they fund that themselves
like you've been doing or how does that
work that's a great question I know that
some have a non-profit partner who's
paying for it but other than that I I
don't know how they do their finances
so is there a Prohibition in the law
somewhere that prevents you from doing
that yes and in the manual procedures
you see we um we have certain events
that we can if we bring in an outside
speaker and we have an attendance list
and that sort of thing it's difficult
when we just want to celebrate our own
staff for those types of things what the
commissioner is getting at when we get
when we have a program for instance we
can celebrate you know the employees in
that way but we have to have an outside
speaker we have attendance list and then
we might be able to get some pizzas or
something like that but there are some
rules that we need to follow under the
manual procedures that the saddle us
with and is that specific to Corrections
or to look at that Statewide Statewide
in uh prior life I worked in the
department of transportation we found a
way around that with having things like
plow rallies you've probably heard of
that and other things where we have
outside entities come in and there's a
lot of volunteer money that comes in
from outside entities as well
interesting uh kind of look at that I
guess yeah if that's in rules the rule
would have would
reference an RSA probably right where
where it generates that we can make sure
we send you the citation there yeah I'll
give you an example our Teamsters Union
I I manage five different unions within
the Department of Corrections uh they
have negotiated language that allows the
department to pay for overtime meals for
those working overtime but our SCA
sergeants and above don't have the same
parallel language so I could buy outside
food to say thank you for now providing
your 100 150 000 hour of overtime to the
teamsters but on the sca sergeants and
above I would say you can have what the
incarcerated people are eating today
seems a little strange
Mike and Melissa I saw you writing
things down so I'm sure you'll get these
references to us and you can take a look
I'll also give you the
example I have our agency suffered a
yep
on duty
oh take your time I will say we just had
in Services yesterday thank you for
we have navigated things as an
organization
through volunteers through generous
donations that I believe
the state should and could respond
better
and making sure funeral services were
paid for the honor that we engaged in
yesterday with a law enforcement walk
through to allow the staff at the
department of corrections to grieve and
respect and honor this person who gave
all
and it is the most poignant example of
things should not be this difficult in
the most obvious situations and I have
followed the statute to the letter as
you would expect me to and written a
letter to commissioner Quinn to review
this as a line of duty death I've also
written to commissioner Maryfield under
that section of law with the attempt to
get the funeral paid for and I sit now
and I wait and we have already completed
our tasks today I do not think that's
just and I do not think that's right
no it isn't Michael and Melissa's look
at that too please
so I thank you for being patient with me
no not at all sorry for you appreciate
Department's loss thank you and at age
43 let me point you back to this age 59
that that is just not the lightning
strike that should be happening to a 43
year old who started with us in 2017 and
now as 19 and 16 year old daughter
so
changing emotional gears take a minute
no I'm gonna push through like I do and
I appreciate that offer uh on page 13
I'll say you know I've known you but
since you took over from Ren and the
Department's in such good hands you're
one of those department heads that I
often Rave about thank you sir again I
it's probably a good time to say that
that you know we're very fortunate to
have you and the staff that you've
pulled together and we've seen such a
turnaround in correction so we want to
make things a little easier here not
have you uh go through what you've gone
through well I appreciate you for that
and I appreciate your accolades it means
a lot to me
thanks
I want to show you on page 13 one of the
most
simple examples of why our agency has
not been able to be competitive on the
front line base salary
these are as of July 15 2022
the
prevailing wages for all state law
enforcement
the lowest paid state law enforcement is
a corrections officer trainee only
second two of fully certified
corrections officer
I don't share this with you to disparage
or attempt to say that the other members
of state law enforcement should not be
paid what they're paid but I share this
with you because
previous administration owed the
responsibility of taking care of this
through the state reallocation process
and
my staff should not be having to work
overtime to try to make up the
difference right and in addition to the
overtime they're having to do because
we're Staffing deficient but at the base
recruitment we're not even competitive
and when the campus Patrol Lieutenant on
the State campus is making more than a
doc Captain who is overseeing 1100
people's lives who are incarcerated and
then some hundred plus employees that's
disproportionate
significantly disproportionate
my the warden at the New Hampshire state
prison for men who has the largest scope
of responsibility makes the same
makes less actually as an unclassified
employee than the executive major at
State Police
so I share this with you because I've
put forward a reallocation packet to the
division of personnel I have to remit to
them the series of the major and our
Internal Affairs investigator because
the state needs to
work with the agency to rectify this
base problem when I put the wage up
the environment up and everything else
up those that step forward are really
The Honorable
and I need to be able to the state needs
to be able to recruit equitably those
that have to meet the same standards as
I referenced before to become based law
enforcement with at least the same base
pay
and we don't have that ability today
and I have I've heard critics say to me
well you have an employee who made 280
000 last year yeah they worked five
doubles they worked five doubles for 52
weeks that is not house one should be
making their income I don't know how
they do it I know they're awake but
that's not healthy and that goes back to
those other statistics
I think this is a
a very transparent way to say we have to
fix this problem
um do you know how your wage
situation relates to counties because I
know a lot of counties have similar
Recruitment and Retention problems and
it's a sad statement but you're probably
all kind of competing with each other I
just wondered if you had a sense of that
representative evil that's a great
question the interesting part that
separates that recruitment is the County
Corrections Officers do not have to meet
the entry level requirements that police
standards and training Council has
established so they don't have to meet
the physical training requirements they
don't have to meet the background check
requirements and they don't have to go
through a police standards and training
Council Academy and pass that they under
police stands and training Council
approve the curriculum and it's all
managed through the county
I think the difference between that
recruitment pool is the State Health
Benefit is different than the
county-based benefit
during covid I was definitely competing
with the counties because they were
quicker on giving covid stipends and
things of that nature to I would work on
the retention side I'm not sure they
were getting a lot of recruitment
but those previous differences have at
least created that separation of
competition everyone is in negotiation
across the state I am aware of what some
counties have negotiated for base pay
and in some of counties negotiate as
high as 27 an hour
um obviously those numbers will come
before the legislature on the state side
and someone asked me how will that help
your agency I said it moves Us in the
same shifting pattern right here it's
just a higher number and the same
disproportion so again using the state
Personnel rule we've put those
reallocation packets to the division of
personnel who will have to analyze and
determine where that labor grade sits
um but that's a it's a very frequent
question I'm asked thank you
any other questions on 13. I guess just
to follow up if I could commissioner one
thing representative evil and I I'm sure
representative Griffin and hatch for me
recall this and being here and maybe
representative McGuire as well there
have been requests by Corrections in the
past to lower if you will the standards
but we've always resisted that feeling
that Corrections offices should be at
the same
expertise training as corrections I mean
as police officers out in the field of
course what we need to do is bring them
up to the same level of pay to the
people up in the field so but that has
come before us I don't know if
commissioner Hanks has done that I know
Rand had requested that on many
occasions and we had said no I
saw a little history thank you for that
history representative McGuire thank you
Mr chair where do these numbers come
from isn't this a collective bargaining
process or something like that so these
numbers thank you for that question I
pulled these from the state wage
schedules and we put them right off the
wage schedules there's two ways in which
uh wages are established yes through
collective bargaining the other is what
is referenced in Personnel rule called
the reallocation process what is
supposed to happen is every year as a
state employee you're supposed to have
your evaluation completed you're
provided your job description and you're
supposed to indicate if that job
description matches the scope of work
that you're doing
this agency I've owned this before and
taking on this leadership role has not
done a good job at that and has never
reflected the changes of these security
Rank and file through that internal
process that's allowed so this is again
a decades-long problem that I've
identified and I'm trying to rectify
through that process so there's two
paths to have this type of situation
worked but
yeah I guess so
so I guess you're saying as part of the
classification process
each job says are you a supervisor or
not are you this and that and and that
gives us sort of salary range to each
job is that is that kind of right and
and and Corrections hasn't
kind of pushed up these let these
particular jobs a little higher is that
representative McGuire it's it's an
interesting question you asked that took
me I think seven years to get an answer
to when I started here as a supervisor
there is literally an algorithm used by
the division of personnel that ranks and
scores different areas of everyone's job
and that score equals a certain labor
grade so the department has to put
together a 13-page packet called a
reallocation packet
submit an updated job description that
adjusts and reflects the actual usually
there's 10 accountabilities in the scope
of your work and the division of
personnel's classification unit analyzes
that and provides a recommendation back
on behalf of the state for what your ask
is as an organization so they do that
it's not as simple as you described they
do a reflective analysis within their
scoring grid of your knowledge skills
ability Education certification all of
those things to affirm what your labor
grade and pay should be
follow
yeah so maybe we need a category of
stress or something like that right that
adds to the to the categories work
environment yeah working something like
that yeah hazardous yeah
so who serves on this classification
unit
so it is a unit within administrative
services division of personnel the state
through the division of personnel is
working on a larger proposal to change
our whole state classification system
and as part of that complete proposal
that will come before the legislature uh
I've remitted those reallocation packets
on purpose in tandem so that this can be
rectified my goal is through that whole
process but it is a unit within the
division of personnel under the
supervision of director Lori rudis
oh interesting
um we occasionally have an outside
entity coming in and assess the state
employees pay I think that was done
about four or five years ago
um are these wages reflected as part of
that or they were not part of that
assessment represent match that's a
great question there's a published
review that was conducted in the last
two years and published on the division
of personnel's website right what I
don't know is what they what did they
use to analyze what they believed the
difference was was it a comparison of
state corrections and Community County
Corrections that would be a
disproportionate comparison
um I don't have any I've asked that
question I don't have an answer to it
yeah it was only two years ago okay it
was and it's published in a PowerPoint
right out on their website oh thank you
while we're talking about money a little
more historic fact and Melissa or Mike
will correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe this uh Department within
division one has the largest general
fund
grab if you will so this is that's why
we spend so much time because it really
all right I know you thought I'd never
get here but page 14 is about
accomplishments
foreign
we are proud that we have made great
strides to create an employee specific
wellness program
um that some of that is described in the
secondary packet we've increased our
capacity to provide substance use
disorder treatment at the highest level
of care based on the American Society of
addiction medicine because substance use
disorder is the number one driver to
reincarceration or recidivism
we've been always proactive starting as
early as 2011 in our engagement in the
tree treatment of opioid use disorder at
the time referred to as
medication-assisted treatment that
acronym and statement has changed and
the more common reference in the field
is the treatment of opioid use disorder
through medication
we have a multi-level treatment path
um we as I mentioned still and do
provide
naloxone as a voluntary opportunity
post-release because the statistics have
affirmed in the first 72 hours
post-release from incarceration that's
the highest risk for overdose for people
with this affliction
we've been accepted and I'm very proud
to representative Evil's questioning and
others into the federal Second Chance
Pell Grant reinitiative we have
partnered with white Mountain Community
College as well as nhti I included in
this page a graphic that investing in
education is one of the and I'm sorry
that the visual is not as wonderful I'll
send you the whole document investing in
education is one of the best things we
can do to reduce recidivism so we're
creating significant Pathways for
post-secondary courses for those who are
under our care and custody we've been
heavily involved with prisons evolving
as connected communities because we have
to progress as a Corrections institution
and recognize we have to create safe
pathways through the internet for people
to engage in in and out like college
courses so we're heavily involved with
that group in addition to participating
with the New England Commission on the
future of higher education behind bars I
myself and my director of rehabilitative
services
participated in numerous meetings
regionally and continue to move the the
pathway forward for education and
Corrections
we've also taken the Choose Love
programming that's been common in our
school systems across the state and
worked with a cast who's a organization
out of Massachusetts to create this in a
Universal Design learning environment
for adults and modified this curriculum
for corrections to help adults use that
same model again to find their own
healing and path forward to reduce
recidivism and create healthier
individuals we've also remitted and I've
partnered with director Henry Henry
Littman of our Medicaid director ask in
our state's 1115a waiver to strengthen
the re-entry efforts for people exiting
incarcerated settings and again be happy
to send you the details of that our goal
and hope in the state of California just
received approval for their ask from the
CMS centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services is for there to be some
coverage through Medicaid at least 45
days prior to release so we can make
face-to-face face or Telehealth
face-to-face encounters between exiting
people their Primary Care Providers and
peer-to-peer programming to reduce the
use of emergency rooms in Urgent Care
the state the legislature did a
wonderful thing when you adopted
expanded medicaid because it affected
the incarcerated population in such a
positive way they did not have a barrier
Cliff anymore now we've worked for years
and years with Medicaid to get people
enrolled in their Medicaid prior to
release and this effort just strengthens
that continuity
any questions on this page these are
just some highlights of those
accomplishments
all right
another quick a quick question I I know
that
HIPAA and all that prevent all this but
there are so many people that are
incarcerated for drug issues and then
they're released and I like what you're
saying here as far as getting them
enrolled and so forth
you don't ever I know it's allegedly
against the rules but you never reach
out to a family and say that your son or
daughter is being released tomorrow and
I just wanted to give you a heads up or
I know that's probably so represent
leishman that's a great question we've
had for greater than 25 years of family
connection center program that's really
targeted youth who have a an
incarcerated parent and we're trying to
expand our I'll call it um reintegration
with family efforts and I think your
question is well stated and we're not
quite there yet but it's another area
we're trying to kind of flip the stone
over we can share that information if we
preemptively received a release so that
we can engage with who they're going to
go live with and help that process I
think there's another opportunity to
come back during the sooner than the
next budget cycle with an accomplishment
that helps adults reconnect with the
family adult system that they have as
other accomplishments we've seen more
recently is our non-corrections officer
positions we are
attempting the tide on that better this
fiscal year so I have the same graphic
here that includes everyone who's not
certified law enforcement in this graph
and that would mean our Behavioral
Health clinicians our counselor case
managers
um
our spiritual leaders there's a whole
Cadre of individuals Incorporated in
here we do have some challenges still on
the logistics but we're starting to see
a steady increase in those other areas I
did include a hyperlink we'll make sure
you get this electronically so you can
click on it but I did purposely type it
all out that last annual report gives
some deep dive into all the things we've
been doing and doing well including the
diversity of mental health groups that
we offer and other areas that are
significant importance
uh including Civic uh volunteerism with
those that are under our custody at
lower levels of classification that are
really helping New Hampshire communities
I tried not to use orange in case
I wanted to be different than the
yeah representative McGuire you were
always on your toes
um on page 16 and if you think of your
question please feel free to ask me uh I
list all the primary infrastructure
challenges specifically for the New
Hampshire state prison for men
um I can go into detail there if you
would like but uh it's it's a tough
situation it's a tough situation
representative evil
I just want to
size what you've said I've seen pictures
and we've toured the place and um
some of it's just scary yeah some of it
is historically scary yeah some we want
to show Engineers now how they did it
so will we be seeing anything on this
list when you come forward I know
there's a obviously you already
mentioned the plans for the
1878 prison but any of these other
short-term fixes uh on your list when
you come to see us
so there's a multitude of challenges
here one is we already have 19 million
dollars worth of capital budget money
right now that currently hasn't been put
out to bid someone's in Stillman design
that's just for the Concord prison
itself
um what we've seen during covet is the
prices just become astronomically high
and of course another challenge that we
have is that in order to work inside a
confined space inside a prison all those
staff members need to be for the
contractors need to be background
checked and a typical day that they work
out in a other building outside of a
prison might be 10 hours long it's
narrowed down to six and seven hours so
the bidders are looking at renovation
costs approaching two thousand dollars a
square foot per square uh per foot
that's that's really hurting us at this
point so we we do have a number of
projects that you're going and you're
going to see some more come forward on
this list uh we
this this is it was a quick bullet
points of the ones that we're dealing
with right now some of them
are worth mentioning
this this is the oldest correctional
facility in the state 1878 the
remodeling was finally complete in the
80s the last building was the age
building in 1990 that was built for 964
inmates as soon as we got in there as
commissioner Hanks is alluded to this
population started to climb we
immediately double bunked everything so
the doors locks and windows and floors
and bathroom fixtures became overused to
a point where we keep coming back and
hitting the operating budget for higher
and higher amounts to do repairs to all
that those facilities uh all that
facility so the Concord Men's prison is
our biggest challenge right now and as
as commissioner Hanks mentioned the
hvacc system is not balanced so this
morning's call we have a Awards call
three times a week and the emphasis is
to
make sure that windows are closed even
the top floors were maybe 80 degrees up
in those areas yes it's nice to open a
window and let it cool down a little bit
on days like we have coming right now
we're going to freeze some pipes so we
have a
Entourage of people ready to to come in
to fix those things over the next couple
of days if we do get some freezing it's
just not an energy efficient facility we
spend over 1.1 million dollars in
electricity a year we spend over
755 thousand dollars in natural gas a
year
uh that's you know 63 000 a month for
water and sewer that and that's because
it's just inefficient to that point with
60 million gallons of water a year in
that facility we use nowhere near that
in the women's facility or in Berlin
because we just have so many leaks and
so many things to take care of
and as I put in some of the I look down
through here and I use some some
New Hampshire lingo there the arch brick
systems that I have camera views on
that's comes from the old systems that
were put in place off North State Street
which was farmland
and basically we put a prison there and
until 1910 there was no electricity
that's the era we're talking about in
comparison 1908 the naval prison was
built in Portsmouth and you can see that
now we're older than Olive
that information is provided it's very
helpful could you not to give you
anything else to do but give us like a
breakdown like you mentioned the
electrical cost the propane costs and
maybe the comparison between the
millions of gallons that you you know
take in but don't seem to get out of the
system type of thing but just that would
be a very good fact sheet for us that's
probably going to prepare it For Your
Right presentation to public works at
all right on page 17
um again some highlights but the packet
I provided you as a separate really
dives into it the unique things we have
done is to create a Corrections uh level
high school curricula that is
implemented in the Berlin high school as
well as now Groveton and we're hoping
that we can find a southern tiered High
School partner to again teach what
Corrections is and what Corrections is
not we are not reality TV we are not
many of the shows that get pushed out
through our digital media outlets and
and movies so it was very important and
to represent the hatch previous question
that's been another pathway post high
school for mature ready high school
graduates to come and work at the
northern Correctional Facility in 2022
we did 63 job fairs and speaking
engagements and we've already done 91
year-to-date calendar year today in 2023
uh so we're really pushing that forward
I've reallocated uh temporarily a
sergeant to do recruitment as a pilot to
see if that was helping us it has helped
us so I will look to make that a more
stable intervention and resource for the
department and make that more part-time
full-time and expand the use of that we
did also create actual part-time
certification to be a corrections
officer that is not a retiree coming
back with the support of police stands
and training Council but it creates a
limited Duty opportunity
to be part-time maybe a college student
maybe someone that's not sure this is a
29 hour a week certification that would
put them in non-direct supervision but
opportunities to help us with our post
requirement and hopefully turn that
part-time employee into a full-time
employee so we're hoping to see that
program come to fruition we have the
permission for the curriculum and
certification through police stands and
training Council
we also uh if you haven't liked us
hearted us care handed us on all those
social media Outlets some of which I
don't even know the names of but
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter you name it
um we're putting things out there I
share that with you with a little
comedic just because even I can grow in
that space But I think there's also a
lot of great information we're putting
out there about what the department is
doing uh doing well and what we're up to
so we've been using those I think a lot
more effectively we did a complete
quality improvement analysis of the
hiring process to make sure we've taken
out all unnecessary stops and steps and
things that slow things down and that's
making great strides
on page eight oh any questions on that
page again there's a robust document
that gets into details even further
on page 18 uh this is our overtime spend
I think the important thing to point out
in 2023 even though that number is
projected to be 18.5 we're doing that
with less people than we did in the year
prior and the year prior to that in
addition to I've safely created training
opportunities for our Correctional line
Personnel those are individuals who work
in our 24 7 facilities as Corrections
professionals who have group two law
enforcement retirement entitlement who
are being trained to also voluntarily
pick posts that we've identified such as
non-arm control rooms triaging and doing
observation for people who are in a
mental health watch to help decrease the
burden on our certified law enforcement
staff in addition to that we've just
recently threw some guidance with the
Attorney General's office created a
release for our other corrections
employees to again be trained in those
safe areas and choose to voluntarily
fill posts if they so choose to so we're
trying to maximize our whole staff who
want to participate in reducing the
burden on our certified Corrections
Officers
we did take the opportunity in July of
in July of 2021 to shut down the second
floor of Hancock building because of the
reduction in population I was able to
say we don't need to use those 194 beds
we will move people around and maximize
other spaces and that helped us reduce
our post requirement daily by 14 posts
so we took to maximize many of those
opportunities including at the women's
prison our population was low enough
that's not the fact today but it was for
some time we were able to shut down one
of the 56 bed general population units
and again that reduced that Daily Post
requirement by five so we've we've
leveraged the population reduction to
try to balance our staffing reduction
um any questions on that page
the very oh go ahead
do you recall how many times you've had
to come to fiscal for a transfer to
handle over time I know it's best we try
to give you enough money for overtime we
never seem to do that or how much money
perhaps well represent policeman that's
a great question because what we asked
for several budget Cycles ago was a
footnote that allowed us to move within
the lines that are funded for for vacant
positions that's been a very successful
footnote for us to use that balance
instead of saying we the agency are
going to ask for 18 million dollars it's
almost a hopeless ask to our staff it
like says we're never going to try to
fix the problem but when the legislature
supported the other methodology has
allowed us to make those balances we
have generally come twice a year through
that process and we will be coming in
March to make a large transfer
all right
so on page 19 knowing today was an
agency overview day I did give you a
glimpse of what we had asked for through
the governor's phase of the budget I do
want to point out some areas of
significance the medical payments to
Providers we do expect to come back
before fiscal this year because the
forecasting on medical in the last
bienum budget was far too low and costs
for health care has increased
significantly areas such as having
enough nursing staff as well as our
contract with our contracted medical and
psychiatric provider did result in
significant increases and other things
that will spell out when I'm before
fiscal so we try to recognize that in
our medical payments to provide our line
You'll see that go up as well as our
impacts on heat electricity and water
new to us as we move forward through the
financing process will be a footnote ask
regarding coming back if our utilities
line is not sufficient given what
director Hansen just shared with you and
this escalating costs on utilities
the other thing you'll see is the
equipment line higher than it's been
before we have depreciated equipment and
we need to rectify that and give our
staff the equipment resources they need
to be successful so those are some key
lines I bring to your attention based on
the information and the process I've
gone through so far
I didn't know if you wanted to go dive
any more deeper or wait till I come back
all right I'll save that representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
um on the salary and benefits line do
you do you have an idea of roughly how
much of that what percentage of that is
salary and retirement costs
versus other Medical
I guess would be the main other part of
that
we'll get that answered okay because the
reason I'm thinking about that is
because when there's overtime the
medical doesn't change but the other
things do change right yeah right okay
we'll get that bridge there all right
thank you
so with that I'm sure I possibly didn't
cover everything I appreciated your
questions and I will Avail myself to any
I wrote down a couple of them so
which is the the crime term yeah the
distribution by crime so when we heard
from the Judiciary drug I asked them the
question what fraction of cases involved
drugs and it was something like I don't
remember it was 60 or 80 percent it was
some very large number but on your page
here they're 11 so what's why is that
different I I believe it's the drug
court and implementation they're not
always turning to incarceration as the
intervention in the case
and they also could be turning to
probation and probation wouldn't show up
on this chart because this represents
people who are sentenced and
incarcerated in a facility
so this big blue line there were no
drugs at all involved in the case or
it's just not the main thing they were
they were you know like I understand
what you're saying because you can be
charged with multiple offenses right
that you could be a drug dealer who
kills another drug dealer so that's
murder right then therefore
so the answer is it's the it is the
latter so your primary index offense is
how you're coded in this chart again so
to give you a point of reference there
are almost 600 men incarcerated for
uh acts against uh aggravated sexual
assault felony sexual assault we have a
180 approximate individuals that are in
war murder uh second degree things that
not assault but homicide things of that
nature
okay it's a mess yeah thank you so 600
sexual assault is is that included
against
um
adults versus children or yep it does
and but I will let you know through my
analysis of the those cases it's most a
higher percentage are against minors
than adults wow all right thank you
representative Ebel or Griffin patch
I'll see none thank you thank you very
much we appreciate your time and your
service to the state
thank you well we appreciate yours more
foreign
all right being just a little after one
we have the dra commissioner nice to see
you and if you could introduce yourself
and the folks you brought with you
that'd be great be happy to to thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
Lindsey stepp and the commissioner at
the New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration with me today is
assistant commissioner Aura Lemire
and business administrator Shelly
grilano
so everyone should have a relatively
brief presentation
and we'll just kind of walk through with
all of you what we do at dra and some of
the highlights of our budget just to
kind of get you thinking before we
actually come and present
so on the second Slide the mission of
the dra is to fairly and efficiently
administer the tax laws of the State of
New Hampshire collecting the proper
amount of taxes due incurring the least
cost of taxpayers in a manner that
merits the highest degree of public
confidence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in the matters of
Budget Finance and the appraisal of real
estate I'll talk about all the lovely
things that we do in the next few slides
on the third slide in terms of taxpayer
interaction it is the policy of the
Department of Revenue Administration to
administer the tax laws of the state in
a manner that demonstrates efficiency
fairness and courtesy to every taxpayer
so we take our taxpayer interaction very
seriously
on page four just a high level
organizational chart you'll see myself
the commissioner and the assistant
commissioner under us there are four
divisions the audit division collections
division Municipal and property Division
and taxpayer services division on the
next few slides I'll go into greater
detail about what each one does and then
we also have the administration unit
which forms performs many of the back
office functions at the dra
so we'll start with the administration
unit on page five as I mentioned the
unit performed administrative functions
necessary to support dra dra operations
this includes the commissioner's office
our business office where Shelley sits
project management tax policy and
legislative analysis you may see from
time to time if you're on any other
committees our tax policy and Analysis
group frequently presents in front of
ways and means Melissa is a veteran of
our tax policy and legislative analysis
group we have our legal Bureau our
hearings Bureau internal audit and human
resources
preserve McGuire thank you
um you skipped over rims rims management
so we're gonna there's a couple of
slides towards the back and we'll talk
about rims rims is our new technology
system
um and so we have employees embedded
within the administration unit that kind
of oversee the operation of rims but
don't worry I've got lots to say about
rims in a few more slides
page six the audit division a lot of
division audits
um the we audit tax returns of
individuals Partnerships Estates trust
corporations and other documents filed
with the dra to ensure compliance with
New Hampshire tax laws and rules our
audit division is generally broken into
an in-state Bureau which audits uh New
Hampshire only taxpayers so your smaller
mom and pop type businesses a
multi-entity bureau that Bureau is
responsible for more of the regional
businesses so say a business that
operates within New England
um the multi-entity Auditors will audit
that business and then we have our
multi-state Bureau and their audits are
primarily focused on the large Fortune
500 companies
we also have a tobacco and Nexus unit
and those folks research federal and
state filings to identify non-filers so
um we'll use some federal data or state
data from other agencies to identify
folks who may have an obligation with
the dra for which we don't have a return
and we'll reach out to them and try to
make sure that they file a return if
need be commissioner I think last
session we gave you more money for
Auditors like to the audit the larger
businesses were you able to hire folks
and how did that work out we have hired
some although we do have some vacancies
as everyone knows we have our facing
hiring challenges like anyone else and
those are really our top level Auditors
so they can be a little bit harder to
hire but we've picked up at least two or
three over the past couple years so that
is good and you're correct there is with
those multi-state Auditors there is
um typically a return on investment for
the additional position does also bring
in Revenue to offset the cost of the
position
now you touched on something as far as
your ability to hire people are you down
like a significant number of folks at
your department our vacancy rate has
kind of hovered around 15 percent we
have had some successes as I've
mentioned with hiring and then you'll
also hear in some of the later slides
when we talk about our new technology
system rims has allowed us to kind of
still do a very efficient job even with
those those vacancies so we've been able
to continue our operations I don't
believe we've seen a significant impact
our folks are working really hard
certainly additional if we were to fill
some vacancies it would relieve a little
bit of pressure but we're able to
function at this point
any other questions as we move along no
okay thank you okay sure
on slide seven the collections division
so this division initiates collection
activities in pursuit of delinquent tax
returns and outstanding payments for all
the taxes that we administer so after a
taxpayer's appeal rights
um have passed and the the debt is final
the collections division are the folks
that will contact them and try to
negotiate payment plans and the like in
order to collect the revenue
this division also monitors the monthly
filings of the meals and rentals tax
returns they issue tobacco licenses and
meals or rentals tax licenses and also
sells tobacco tax stamps question from
of airbnbs
and other individuals that are renting
primary homes for weekends that seems to
be more and more prevalent how do you
track those
so there's kind of two options if you um
own a home
um that you rent on the weekends
um if you own if you rent that
um home you know on your own say through
Facebook posts or newspaper listings you
would need a meals and rentals tax
license and you would collect the tax
from the people staying at your home and
remit it to us on a monthly basis
if you rent your property through either
a rental agent or through an online
platform like an Airbnb or a verbo
something like that typically those
operators will collect and remit the tax
on your behalf so you don't have to do
that individually and you would operate
under their own license
so I guess if I may Mr chair a little
more interested in those that do it on
their own without uh Airbnb Airbnb type
so how how do you monitor those because
there's no formal entity that they're
working through so so the advertisements
there is a requirement in the statute
that the advertisements should show
their m r license number that went into
place a few years ago as a way an easier
way for us and other folks to identify
that that operator is operating under
the laws and statutes of the state so if
I may are you still month and you
monitor app for ads We Will We Will okay
and we also have and I'll show this a
little bit later too but there is um
ways that we have a tax fraud
um online form for people to fill out
anonymously so if there's a concern that
your neighbor might be renting out their
property and not following the laws you
can submit um Anonymous referrals and we
get those from time to time as well
sure so how often does that happen did
you get a neighbor saying that someone
it happens with somewhat regularly yep
it's a nice easy online form
um and
um
and and we we will follow up and pursue
those to make sure
um that it is either licensed properly
or not and if it's not we'll work with
okay moving on to slide eight
the municipal and property division so
the division establishes and improves
Municipal School County and Village
District tax rates so we set all tax
rates uh proper local property tax rates
in the state of New Hampshire we also
provide technical assistance in training
in Municipal and budgeting and finance
for municipalities
we Monitor reappraisals and certify tax
assessors the folks that are out in your
communities determining the assessed
value of your properties
we equalize locally assessed values of
municipalities to full level so this is
something that's come up frequently in
the past couple years of as we've seen
such dramatic changes in property values
municipalities are only required to
reassess properties do a full
revaluation every five years
when we've seen what we have in the in
the recent years where within a
five-year period values can change
rather dramatically the point of this
Equalization process is to bring all
properties within the state to full
market value
we also appraise public utilities and
railroad property for the administration
of those taxes we administer the
Timberland the Graver Timber and gravel
taxes also known as Sticks and Stones
those are two taxes that are collected
uh Baidu municipalities but the dra has
experts in both of those areas and so we
assist the municipalities in the
administration of those taxes
and we provide a statutory support to
two different administratively attached
boards the assessing Standards Board and
on slide 9 our taxpayer services
division this is the division that kind
of handles all routine interactions for
taxpayers in the department so they
receive process and store all of our tax
documents so they process all of the
returns that come in and a lot
electronic transactions and payments
they manage our forms development for
forms that are filed with the dra and
they provide general assistance to the
public they are the persons that if you
ever call into the dra they man our call
center we have a five-person call center
they receive wonderful reviews so if you
ever have any questions feel free to
call in and they also maintain taxpayer
accounts so if someone calls in with or
writes in with a question or concern
about their accounts they perform the
account maintenance
the last area that I wanted to highlight
is the Department of Information
Technology we have embedded Personnel at
the dra that are critical obviously to
the technology and functions that we
perform
on slide 10 we are the primary tax
collector for the state so taxes
administered by the dra we collected
collect just under three billion dollars
in Revenue I've listed out I won't walk
through all of them but for easy
reference I've listed out all of the
taxes that we administer the current
rate of that tax and then the associated
statute I will just mention we do not
collect the insurance premium tax the
beer tax or the road toll also known as
the gas tax
but basically everything else runs
2.9 billion is this a um biennium or an
annual annual I see all right thank you
that 2.9 billion is broken out on slide
11 so you can see by tax type how we
arrived at that number business taxes
are obviously the largest portion but
we've included everything here again as
an easy reference and then on slide 12
there's a nice pie chart if you prefer
to look at things that way as well
um that 2.9
um
2.9 billion is roughly 80 percent of the
general and education trust fund
um so again we are the primary revenue
collectors for the general and education
on slide 13 we'll talk a little bit
about rims so rims is our Revenue
information management system
we received a 30 million one hundred and
sixty thousand dollar Capital
appropriation through General funds and
other funds funds to replace our aging
tax information management system also
known as Tims
Tim's was implemented in 1990 it was a
black screen green flashing cursor no
ability to use a mouse it was all
function keys so it it had served us
well for many years but it had certainly
reached the end of its life it was
limited in in its functionality it was
um causing some concerns about
reliability usefulness and security of
taxpayer data so we went forward with
modernizing with rims rims is used not
only by the dra but also with tax
practitioners and taxpayers as well
we implemented rims in partnership with
doit and it is a complete back-end
technology system which houses and
Consolidated all of our taxpayer data so
Tim's when we were operating under that
system only had our largest tax types
and the other taxes lived in disparate
systems access databases Etc rims now
brings everything together into one
place
fast Enterprises was selected through an
RFP process to implement and support
their commercial off-the-shelf product
called gen tax so rims is the New
Hampshire version of gentax gentax
operates in many many many States
cities and counties across the country
so it is a very well-versed system
um implementation consisted of three
phases each one took about a year and
the contract also included support and
maintenance of the system for four years
the total cost for that system was 29
000.
thank you Mr chair uh what year was it
implemented in so if you flip to the
next slide sorry short note no worries
thank you um I'd walk through here the
three rollouts that we used to implement
the system so the first rollout went
live on October 28th of 2019 that
included our meals and rentals tax and
then the Medicaid enhancement tax and
the nursing facility quality assessment
rollout 2 went live on October 5th of
2020 included both of our business taxes
interest and dividends tax and
communication Services tax and then the
final rollout went live about a year and
a half ago on August 9th of 2021 and
included our tobacco tax real estate
transfer tax utility property tax
railroad Private Car
sticks and stones and also the low and
moderate
homeowners relief program
I will point out these all of these
rollouts were on time and on budget we
had no additional costs everything went
live as planned even during a global
pandemic with shifts to everyone working
from home
um it was quite an undertaking it was a
lot of hard work and I'm very very proud
of the work that the dra doit and our
vendor fast did in order to get this up
and running
you'll see on slide 15 this is a
screenshot of what Granite tax connect
looks like so Granite tax connect is the
public portal option of rims so if you
go to the Granite tax connect website
you will see these various options where
either you can sign into your account up
at the top or you can do a variety of
functions down below
you can register or apply for an
application say for a meals and rentals
license if you were operating or
deciding to rent out your property and
needed an m r license you could apply
for one right here on the home page you
can make a payment you can find file
documents related to the real estate
transfer tax you can find a previous
submission or you'll see in that second
box down all the way on the left that's
where you would report tax fraud or
concerns about tax fraud
you can submit certification requests if
you're looking say for a certificate of
good standing or something of the
similar and then on the bottom right is
reporting so you can look up meals and
rentals tax licenses tobacco tax
licenses Etc so nothing existed like
this before rims there was no ability
for taxpayers to log into their account
and see if their payment had posted or
processed you know if you sent in a
check and it looked like it hadn't been
cached yet you'd have to call us we're
very nice we answer the phones I promise
but it's an added headache right now you
can create an account your practitioner
can have access to your account if you
so choose and they can monitor your
account for you or you can log in and
make sure that that check was actually
cast cached and that payment was
on slide 16 I just wanted to highlight
something interesting about the
financing of rims so we received the
capital appropriation during the 2012
legislative session 2017 excuse me
legislative session
and we received the 30 million one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars for
rims and then the front-end taxpayer
portal of granite tax connect which I
showed you on the prior slide
24 million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars of that appropriation
was financed through the issuance of
bonds
and those are to be the be paid for by a
non-lapsing revenue information
management system account
so we at the dra can transfer up to four
million dollars a year of Revenue that
we receive into this non-lapsing account
in order to pay the principal and
interest on the bond the 24 million one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars of
bonds so the capital budget really only
funded the six million dollars the
difference between the 30 million and
the 24 million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in this rims Revenue
uplift is going to finance the remaining
on slide 17 I show you what we have
transferred into that rims information
management system account in fiscal year
2020 we didn't transfer anything we were
not yet fully up and running
in fiscal year 21 we transferred 2.2
million and then in fiscal year 22 we
transferred the full 4 million you'll
see in the table at the bottom that we
actually generated 5.3 million in
Revenue uplift however per the statute
were capped at the 4 million maximum so
we kind of prorated the amount to be
transferred
this Revenue uplift
um to date is generated by a reminder to
pay letters so before rims if we sent
you a tax notice because you owed us
money we would never have we didn't have
the ability to follow up with you to
remind you and the next communication
you would get for us was that your
appeal rights had expired and you were
now in collections
we now send you a reminder after 30 days
because we understand people are busy we
understand that mail can get lost in the
shuffle so after 30 days we send you a
reminder
by just sending that reminder we have
generated over two million dollars of
Revenue that we hadn't received
previously
we also now have a greater ability to
use federal tax information so I
mentioned that earlier one of the
functions of our audit division is to
identify either
non-filers or discrepancies between
Federal filings and state filings this
the state business tax returns starting
point is the Federal Business is federal
return We but for rims we didn't have
the ability to make a lot of those
connections so we have the ability now
to have greater use of the data that we
receive from the IRS to make sure that
so if I could Commission
compliance how do we rank as far as
maybe other states or are you having
problems uh collecting in any particular
tax bracket area
the question
um
I would say
a pretty good job with our compliance
it's hard to compare to other states
because if if Massachusetts was sitting
here their primary concern would be
personal income tax we don't have a
personal income tax so our you know
concerns are a smaller population of
taxes
um but we
um use the data that's provided to us as
I mentioned either through federal tax
information or through information from
other state agencies like Employment
Security or for instance um The Liquor
Commission when they issue a liquor
license they'll let us know so we can
make sure that the operator also has a
meals and rentals license because they
would they are going to be selling
taxable items
um and so I think we do we do a nice job
we
um I believe our Communications are
courteous so if we reach out to you and
we believe you have a filing obligation
but we don't see a return we don't
immediately just send you a tax notice
that says hey we did the math for you
you know here's the amount that you owe
we'll reach out and say we believe you
have a filing obligation and we'd like
to just understand why we haven't
received a return and sometimes there is
a reason and other times the taxpayer
will say I wasn't aware that I had a
filing obligation and will work with
them to get into compliance yeah I
appreciate that you know you've always
heard that nobody likes to tax man we
try
but in your case I guess they probably
like the tax woman better than they've
like yeah in the past but no thanks any
questions yes representative thank you
hi thank you thanks for coming
um I was just curious I know that we're
uh changing the way we're uh handling uh
business profits tax to the single sales
Factor how does that affect your agency
operationally when they're a such big
changes so
I would say the biggest impact to our
agency will use the single sales Factor
as an example so previously there were
three factors that a business and the
dra would look to
um when reviewing a business's
operations if they operated in multiple
States so the the single sales Factor
comes in with how does Acme Corporation
decide how much of their profit should
go to Massachusetts versus New Hampshire
versus Vermont versus Maine
so when we used three factors we all
understood how that worked now we're
just looking at this the sales Factor so
it's not a huge change for us it's just
a slight change in methodology but I
would say more of the impact is it's
going to depend on what year we're
looking at in terms of if we're under
audit or if we're working with a
taxpayer to come into compliance we need
to look at what tax year they're
operating in to determine how they
should be calculating their
apportionment so it kind of takes a
couple of years you know you'll you'll
hear employees be like okay wait a
second am I looking at three single
sales factor or am I looking at three
Factor apportionment
um it was a pretty easy change to make
within our new system which is another
benefit
um so it's really just kind of
remembering that the change has occurred
and what you need to do in what year if
question representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman thank you
what fraction of taxes collected end up
going to the collections department
because they're not paid
oh that's a good question we can get you
that information it would depend on
um on the tax type so meals and rentals
operators right they file on a monthly
basis we look returns are due on the
15th by about the 20th of the month if
we don't have a return for you we'll
send you a reminder
um so that that tax we're kind of
dealing with and on an ongoing basis so
in theory unless they can't pay the
amount we've kind of are keeping them on
their toes to make sure they file and
pay business taxes interest in dividends
tax it's only you know due on a yearly
basis
um there might be more amounts that end
up in collections but we can get you
that information that's a good question
um yes thank you so
and what and I'd also like to know what
fraction of those end up going to legal
action or whatever you do
the next steps that when the collection
says I can't find this person or
whatever yeah yep we can definitely get
you that information I would assume it's
small right the one percent or some tiny
number do you know or I don't know off
the top of my head or do you know off
the top of your head
um
no as far as enforcement action I think
it's wrong 80
collections enforcement which is usually
after about two years period
but the other question how much it
actually gets the collections yeah
thank you you're welcome
it's nice to hear though that you're
sending out a reminder notice instead of
the next note is being a certified
letter or something like that but you're
at least making a strong effort to get
the word out that something is owed or
do or whatever
so obviously we operate somewhat in a
voluntary compliance system right and a
tax administrator in the state of New
York told me years ago about this
concept of like a compliance Continuum
and the more that you can do
um to re to collect the money and
receive it and the information up front
the lower cost it is not only to the
department but also to the taxpayers so
whatever we can do do to avoid the more
advanced collection
actions is going to not only be better
for the taxpayer but also better for us
so a simple reminder letter is really
relatively low cost gentle reminder to
the taxpayer can generate revenue and
everybody wins so another question so
when the tax is late is there a certain
uh percentage charge or something uh
late fee and is it the same across all
sets of taxes or or different it can be
different across um sets of taxes there
are penalties and interests uh penalties
and interest Associated
um with any late payments or late
filings
um I as the commissioner do have the
authority to Abate those for good cause
and we routinely work with taxpayers and
if it is an honest mistake we're not
going to stick you with a large bill
um for you know being a couple days late
any further questions as we move along
no okay
uh slide 18 just some highlights of our
24 25
agency budget that will be back before
you again in a few weeks to present
um our current position count is
maintained at 156 full-time classified
and unclassified employees and four
part-time positions so we administer 2.9
billion dollars in Revenue with 160
people so we're a pretty efficient shop
our general fund operating budget is 70
75 salaries and benefits we are a
department of people and not things or
programs so primarily salaries and
benefits when you're looking at our
budget
our budget request includes sufficient
funding for employee training
out-of-state travel for audits overtime
for Peak periods and taxpayer services
and in collections and maintaining a
free fleet of state-owned cars that our
in-state auditor use use and also our
property appraisal staff and postage for
Dra Communications to taxpayers the
additional reminder to pay letters Etc
that we're sending have increased our
postage costs over the the past couple
years but obviously to great benefit
um there are no budget increases for
one-time State Workforce efficiency
enhancement program or sweep projects
the dra received funding for three of
these sweep projects where we will be
using arpa funds in order to make
enhancements and upgrades to systems at
dra we're going to get a new brand new
high-speed scanner that helps us process
the mail we're going to make upgrades to
rims and also upgrades to our property
appraisal software those are all
one-time costs so there's no you won't
see any requests in our operating budget
in order to
um
uh sustain any costs related to those
individual projects over the biennium
the division directors business office
and other managers work well
um together and we work hard to budget
conservatively and accurately really for
just we what we need we try to limit our
wants and just come up with the budget
that's going to work for us
on slide 19 our prioritize needs so our
efficiency budget as submitted
maintained all current operations
however there were areas where the dra
has requested additional funding in
terms of prioritized needs the first is
the low and moderate income hardship
grants so these are paid for out of the
education trust fund and chapter 95 from
2021 increased the income limitations
and the amount of Maximum relief that is
paid out under l m
and so that resulted in an increase in
the number of claims and an increase of
the amount of money that we paid out so
for the April 1st 2021 tax year we had
just under
um 6 000 claims for 1.4 million compared
to roughly 5 500 claims for 800 000 for
the prior year so our prioritized need
does ask for an additional 700 000 in
order to fund those additional claims
questions on that okay on page 20 we
also have an additional
um prioritized need for our Rim system
um the 30 million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollar Capital appropriation
includes hardware and software
maintenance through 2025 but does not
include software maintenance or consult
oh and only and also I'm sorry and also
include software maintenance Consulting
through the first quarter of 24. we are
requesting to maintain that level of
consulting services from our vendor
through 2025.
so that will allow us to continue to
operate at our current levels with rims
the reason why we're asking for it now
and we didn't put it in the original
capital budget request is because we
weren't sure of the amount of consulting
services that we would need and because
we hadn't implemented the system yet and
I didn't at the time want us to either
underfund or over fund those services so
we waited until we were through
implementation and we now feel like we
have a good handle on the on the level
of service that we need so that's why
that amount was not in the original
capital appropriation
we are also requesting funding for two
years oh sure thank you
um do you have a dollar amount for that
um
we'll come back with what's in the
um we're also requesting funding for two
doit positions that are currently
unfunded I mentioned at the beginning of
the presentation we obviously have
embedded staff at dra
um 40 to 60 of them are eligible to
retire so we are looking to
add some additional positions get some
new bodies have the knowledge transfer
occur before the retirements happen so
that's what those two positions are for
a little bit um secession planning and
knowledge transfer
and then lastly on slide 21 just some
updates on our budget
um our 2223 budget
um
we as I mentioned went live with our
final rollout of rims I mentioned at the
beginning that the efficiency of the
system really helped us maintain our
level of operations during a period of
time when we've seen a roughly 15
vacancy rate so certainly the system is
proving to be quite valuable
um I mentioned the amounts that we have
been able to generate from revenue
uplift
and then lastly this was a topic of
conversation kind of during the during
the last budget process so just updates
on kind of customer service I've alluded
to it a bit as we've talked today
um it is a priority at dra in 22 FY 22
and 23 to date
um we have a survey that if you call
into our call center at the end of the
call you're asked to fill out a survey
if you'd like to stay on a lot on the
line we've received a rating of three or
higher on a scale of one to five in 98
of the calls
um
callers also have the opportunity to
leave a message if they would like and
they typically say things like thank you
so much for answering your phones I
tried to call the IRS no one answered I
really appreciate someone taking the
time to to walk me through what I needed
today
um
obviously the online portal of granite
tax connect
allowing taxpayers and practitioners to
make payments check account statuses Etc
has been a huge customer service benefit
for us we have over 30 000 GTC users so
we have over 30 000 people that use that
online portal to interact with us and it
certainly made their lives easier we
also have the ability that if you call
into our call center and you're in GTC
and you're stuck you can't figure out
where you're supposed to click next or
where you're supposed to enter the
information there's a little number that
shows up and if you give that number to
our call center agent we can see what
you're doing and we can help you walk
walk you through the program and so
that's also been a huge benefit of the
system as well
foreign
so that's what I have for today so you
mentioned the users and the program in
about what thirty thousand three one
thousand what percent of the folks
paying taxes in the state use that
portal so I have those numbers for you
and I can definitely get them the vast
majority of our users are our meals and
rentals tax operators they in order to
keep their three percent commission they
need to file electronically and so they
do through via do so via GTC
our business tax filers it depends
um if they are a smaller business they
tend to use GTC if they are a larger
business that may have their own tax
operation within the business or may
contract most of that work out to a CPA
or the like they may not utilize GTC as
much our interest in dividends taxpayers
it can depend
um obviously you all know a lot of those
interest and dividends taxpayers
um
our elderly
um they file paper returns they don't
have much interest in GTC and that's
totally fine by us we would never force
them to use that so it's nice to have it
as an option for folks that want to use
it
um but it is definitely not mandated we
still accept paper returns we accept
term returns through software providers
um so I feel like we have a pretty good
uptake with GTC we've been happy with
the number of users that we've seen
so my final question flood control I was
surprised I didn't see it how is that
really was there a settlement there was
a settlement yes so I didn't include
flood control because with the help of
the Attorney General's office we reached
a settlement with the state of
Massachusetts we have not yet received
payment but we anticipate receiving the
payment for the years that have been
outstanding so at least for one year I
left it out of the presentation
here for those of you that know it they
oversee the flood control payments we
have a compact along with Vermont and
Connecticut and mass that they provide
the towns and the state for the land
that was taken for flood control and
Mass has been somewhat
limited as far as some of the payments
yes so that is a very nice way to put it
yeah the state is actually made up the
holes in the past with General funds to
make those communities whole so it's
been kind of a nagging problem but the
commissioner has been very good in
trying to keep that together yes so it's
we
you're okay for this year okay
it's not so much a question as it is
just a comment so I remember really well
the 30 million dollar discussion for the
for the rooms I mean I think we've had
like this push-pull whether a software
update really is an operating issue
versus a capital issue but we've
reconciled that it it it's going into
the capital budget but we I just
remember when working on these things
the I.T expenses are just enormous and
were capped for bonding for General
funds at something like
120 million and you know 30 million was
a huge chunk and it was a really so
we've I know that they've really
struggled on the capital budget sort of
uh weighing the I.T needs against the
actual you know Sticks and Bricks or
whatever
so yeah right so you know the leaking
roofs it's it it creates um
creates challenges but obviously the I.T
improvements had a huge effect for your
age a huge effect
um it really has you know brought us
into current times
um it allows our employees and our
managers to operate more efficiently and
effectively and you know the benefits to
the taxpayers and the tax practitioner
Community is there as well so it's
really beneficial all around and like I
said it was a lot of hard work
um but I'm very proud of what we what
further questions representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman commissioner um
did I hear you say at the beginning that
15 of the positions are unfilled
so instead of these two new positions
for experience couldn't you fill a
couple of those and and use them in that
way so the 15 vacancy rate is for my dra
positions
two new ones are really doit positions
that sit at dra I see okay thank you
very much we're worthy of discussion
yeah yeah and and
um similarly uh call center you said so
we now have more online does that mean
you've been able to reassign call center
people to do other tasks or whatever we
do so our five-person call center their
primary function is to answer the phones
in a time where we don't get a lot of
phone calls they are also trained to do
other account maintenance work so if
times are slow they're not just sitting
there twiddling in their thumbs waiting
for the phone call to come in they have
other work to do alternatively there are
times like during tax filing season
where five people would never be enough
to answer all the calls and we would
have really long wait times so we also
have other members of staff that are
trained to supplement the call center
during those higher peak times so it but
again rims is one of the things that has
allowed us to better do that because
there's simple things in rims there's a
button that says get next task
so you don't have to go searching for
work if you have a couple of slow
minutes on the phones you can log into
rims and just say give me something to
do and it pops something up for you to
do yeah
yeah may I ask one more sure what's the
least efficient tax to collect in the
sense that the collection cost is is a
higher percentage of the amount
collected
I would probably just by Logic be those
taxes that
um generate the smallest amount of
Revenue
um so if you look on slide 11
um
the you know communication Services tax
is just under 30 million I mean you know
you'll see when you get our uh
our operating budget we're nowhere near
30 million
um dollars spent in total at dra so I
don't think there's anything that
you know
flips the wrong way where it costs more
to collect it than we generate but those
smaller taxes maybe the one most
um
that would fall into that category
would be and will be the interest in
dividends tax as it phases out and it
gets to that you know two percent one
percent
um tax rate there are 70 roughly 70 to
75 000 taxpayers of the interest in
dividends tax they file a five-page form
with us every year
um so there is a lot of administration
that goes into that tax and when that
tax rate gets quite low granted it's
only going to be for a brief period of
time but as that tax rate gets quite low
we're doing a lot of work for not a lot
of paper there it's a lot of paper for a
lot of not a lot of Revenue
I was hoping you're going to say the
railroad
[Laughter]
Ed so you said about 75 000 interest in
dividends that that many taxpayers yeah
and a lot of those are zero returns
right so they currently meet the filing
threshold but there is also an exemption
that's equal to the filing threshold so
they have to file but they don't have to
pay so they file a five-page return with
no money
well seeing no more questions
um Lindsay's one of our my favorite
Commissioners she had a huge shoes to
fill when John beardmore left and you're
you've more than filled his shoes you do
great job thank you very much great
confidence thank you
all right I did receive uh
a communication from the speaker that
it's now over 15 below zero air
temperature outside so if anyone is down
at stores they are welcome to go get
their vehicle and bring them into the
LLB parking garage there's plenty of
spaces so any of you that are down at
stores yeah yeah
you're welcome to go and get your car
and bring them up because it's only
going to get colder so
and we do have a good 10 minutes before
we start again
thanks Lindsay thank you all very much
well I think it would be better if you
sat by yourself no you're absolutely
and if you turn you know there you go hi
I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of
um administrative services
of something
and a constituent of one of yours
so because I live in Canterbury
there you go
um
so I'm sorry with me Cassie Keane is our
Deputy Commissioner Karen rentomaki is
our director of plant and property
because I figured we might get into
property issues
um and Sherry Rockburn who's our
assistant commissioner would have been
here but um as you may know that this is
High season for the budget and I believe
that she's connected at the hip to the
governor's budget director this week so
I excused her for being here I wanted to
talk to you a little bit about
um I thought about this presentation a
little bit
um before
that's a good sign right that I thought
about it before I came here
um I thought about a little bit and what
what was a good thing to do when and uh
most of the numbers have been removed
from the presentation because I think
that would be useful
um who are we and what do we do uh or
who are we and why are we here that's an
another question
um
I want to talk about who we are more
broadly speaking though I'm going to get
into a little bit about how we're sort
of two different pieces of agency and
I'll it'll be the one number I talk
about we're essentially retiree health
and we're an agency and I'm going to
talk to you at first about the agency
administrative Services is kind of a
weird thing when you think about it it's
not descriptive in most particular ways
like if banking is here you'll probably
understand that they do banking
and that if the Liquor Commission is
here you probably would guess that they
sell liquor and if Insurance were here
you would think anybody Insurance
um and you'd be right and administrative
Services people like oh so you service
administrative things or it's not clear
we're uh we're a diverse agency that's
often difficult to describe but if you
think about it we have eight major
divisions um that we do and I'm going to
go into them in more depth but a quick
overview the state budget office is part
of our agency and it's um you know to
say budget is obviously a big thing
probably this committee is aware of that
um accounting services is one of our
agencies in some states the Comptroller
is an elected official
um in New Hampshire it's it's one of our
division directors in this agency we do
the state's books we don't do the books
every year we we couldn't open for
business the next year which would be
awkward being a state government
um to say the least purchasing one of
the oldest pieces of our agency is
actually purchasing started in 1915
the state hired a purchasing agent but
we buy things we we do Statewide
procurement a lot of ancillary functions
that are associated but that's that's
one of them
um what used to be called fdm and it's
now called eam which is the state's
computer system we don't do the hardware
that's the oit but the giant piece of
software the enterprise system that
governs everything we do Budget Finance
the payment of more than 12 000 people
every two weeks
um their paycheck is within our agency
that's a really big function that's
often not noticed we do risks and
benefits the state's health care plan
various insurance policies Etc it's a
very important thing the paycheck may be
the most important thing to most state
employees their health insurance is
probably almost certainly the second
um and and that's a big function very
complicated function that we perform
Statewide Personnel offices are is part
of our agency the division of personnel
Public Works is one of the pieces of our
agency see we don't build roads and
bridges that's dot but everything else
we're responsible for building we have a
team of Architects and Engineers who any
project over twenty five thousand
dollars
so save that thought because we have
some questions on Public Works projects
I bet you will so and then uh somewhat
related to that is plant and property
it's actually our largest division it's
Karen by the way
um is uh
um and Karen is an engineer Cassie's a
lawyer and I I have no discernible
talent and so that's that's why I'm here
um and so we uh we manage more than 91
state buildings and we manage them
within the appropriation which with
which were granted which is to say that
we do the best we can with the money we
have and if you've been in some state
buildings you walk around and go it's
pretty nice
if you've been in other state buildings
that's not what you say
um and we can have a meeting sometime in
the conference room that I use most days
in our basement and everybody from the
outside who comes in goes like this oh
this is
scary
um but but like I say we do the best we
can and we do and a great staff that
does a really good job it's a lot of
diverse functions and there there's a
weirdness to it if you think of that
Spectrum I'm going to use two examples
Public Works and personnel
nobody I feel confident in saying this
has ever applied to both of those
divisions for a job
and it's thinking well I was going to go
with architect but I'm thinking to do an
HR instead
um and so why are they both part of
administrative Services it's weird
um what we have in common is that we're
a central Service Agency
we don't regulate Banks we don't sell
liquor we don't we don't run the lottery
we don't run the state's Medicaid
Program but none of those people can do
their job if we don't do ours not a
single one every day in every way
everything that we do impacts the entire
rest of state government we deal on a
daily basis with with essentially every
other department some not daily but
there's none that we don't deal with at
least once a week and there's an
enormous responsibility in that there's
a there's an honor in that a privilege
in it too and it's a privileged um I
talk about it actually when we when we
do hiring I do a I do a final interview
with um everybody that we hire and it's
one of the things I talk about there's a
there's an honor it's a lot of work it's
a ton of work and it's a ton of work
that we that we try to do the best we
can with the resources that we have but
you know that every day people are
relying on you and and
um I like that some people like to work
in a closet by themselves I'm not one of
those we're part of a team
Richard Petty doesn't win the race by
driving left all day right and and I
hope everybody knows who Richard Petty
is
um the crew uh is critically important
to that the people who tune the engine
the people change the tires and people
put gas in the car and that's who we are
we're the crew
um
I'll mention I went through the
divisions and and I'm happy to talk in
in a greater detail
um about some of them but
um just some of the high points Health
Care risk and benefits uh it's a 500 500
million dollar per biennium health care
plan it's a big spend it's a big piece
of what you do
but one of the biggest chunks of that is
retiree health and I'll talk to you in a
minute about how
retiree health is a benefit that's paid
it's not an operation of the department
it's something that we operate but when
we budget like like you you don't look
at it and go I need you to lapse more
out of retiree health I need you to cut
you know four percent across the board
and eliminate positions now it's half of
our Department's budget but it's a it's
a big uh it's a big thing it's a big
benefit that we provide
um accounting the department was created
um although pieces of a date back
further was created as the office of the
Comptroller and before that the state
didn't have a budget in 1931 and what
would happen is agencies would run out
of money three quarters his way through
a year and would come back to the
legislature and go hey we're out can we
have some more
and somebody decided that wasn't an
appropriate way to do business and that
we should have a budget that function if
you read the original Law the state
budget law hasn't really changed
dramatically there's some important
differences but not dramatically since
then but we pre-audit payments to make
sure that when you write a check you
have money in your budget to pay the
check that's a very important thing it's
not something that was done before that
and um you know we process more than 200
000 audited payments a year which is you
know kind of a lot
um and that in that division oversees
State Payroll which is you know always
it's not a matter of sitting down
writing a couple of paychecks it's as a
complicated accounting process involved
in that
um software like I say the state the
piece of software that runs state
government
um is managed by eam
the facility management I talked about
91 buildings more than 4 million square
feet of office space
um probably more than 3 million square
feet in the city of Concord alone we
manage Court facilities we manage this
building we manage a lot of buildings in
Concord and all across the state that is
a complicated process and it's why I
talked to Karen more than
almost anybody because there's always
something
breaking I was gonna say braking
um that we're improving how about that
there's always something getting better
um like this weekend I haven't I have an
email in my inbox about what we're doing
uh to make sure that negative 15 degree
weather doesn't
mess us up
um and I would say a lot purchasing is a
big thing that everyone's aware of
um the state buys things and buying
things for the state is very different
um we manage all the Statewide contracts
and we also manage all Commodities
it's it's an important function for two
reasons one is that you know we we
typically almost always bid projects a
to get a good price but B so that
everyone in the state has a shot at the
state's business because we're the
government because it's taxpayer dollars
um we don't get to say at some point I
like Tony we should make sure we let's
give tony the contract he's a good guy
he'll do a good job
Tony doesn't get the contract Tony has
to Bid And so can Bob and so can Karen
and so can Sally everybody gets to bid
and that's a very important function and
some responsibility
Personnel is a is a big thing everyone
knows the challenges right now in hiring
um large vacancy rates hiring you know
labor labor markets across the country
are very tight and it's a problem here
we also manage the collective bargaining
process it is the governor who signs
with the Union I'm sorry what's 15
unions 15 14 14. it keeps going up it
would be a lot easier if there if there
weren't 14 but um
um but but we do that that's a big part
of the process
so since we're on Personnel now I
embedded in that division
I believe you have a group that looks at
salaries and we just heard from Helen
Hanks the commissioner of of course you
know Corrections and the incoming
Corrections Officers are like the lowest
paid
and I believe she's reached out to your
group to look at that where does that
all stand because as you know that's
just one of the many many agencies that
are being forced to into long overtime
shifts and losing people left and right
so where does all that stand well um let
me talk more broadly about about
personnel and then a little bit about
corrections um
the state operates in in in two two
different
um
environments that that limit to some
extent flexibility and on purpose uh the
one is a classification system and the
other is a set of Union contracts which
which are all designed to say that I
can't pay you what I want to pay you I
can't say well I think you're doing a
good job so I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
ten Grand more than I then I give Cassie
because she's okay
um and uh everybody gets the same amount
so in the classification system you are
meant to in any large organization in
all governments are like this you are
meant to analyze every position in
government according to a set of
criteria that we establish in our case
it's a nine Factor plan that was first
established in roughly 1950
um
and you evaluate every position against
that and decide what where the position
should fall what labor grade and then
you assign salaries by steps Etc
and in addition to that collective
bargaining influences how much people
get paid and so Corrections Officers if
you will would be classified according
to job content is the way to think about
that and then they would be placed in
the grid but collective bargaining
effects that correction officers I think
everyone knows this have their salaries
have gone up significantly more than
average state workers over the last six
years and a very large increase in in
the 18 collective bargaining I think
some don't hold me to something like
nine percent when everybody else was got
three and a half
and then um
and then the next year I think they got
I think was 14 months but I think that's
over three years yeah and so they got a
raise one year when nobody else got a
raise and then the last year everybody
else got the same amount so their
salaries have been going up but I know
that that it's a challenge because
um
I gather you go through the academy and
you're then qualified to do police
service and you could do something else
in let's just say a town or somewhere
else where you might make more money and
you don't have to work inside a prison
which is occasionally a uh selling point
for those jobs so
so that's there okay so it's well in
your radar I guess well and so one of
the things you you can do with any
position is any group of employees can
position uh petition or a supervisor
hiring manager can look at a
classification right because it's never
a position I mean it can be opposition
that's misaligned and you ask them to
look at it and say is it correctly
aligned is it correctly allocated or
classified classified as a word we
typically use for a group of them we
often say an allocation and there is a
reallocation analysis being done on that
I don't actually know where the status
of it but I could look it up you don't
know do you I don't so that's that yeah
if you could get back to Mr Hoffman or
Melissa yeah I'll let you know where we
stand early on our radar absolutely to
say one more thing on the Personnel
issue well we're there yes
so a year or so maybe less ago you came
to fiscal for an incentive package to
try to keep people here and how is that
going is that
helped at all or I think I don't know
that I don't want to claim we've done a
there's an incent there are a set of
incentive payments that have been passed
for for various groups of people one is
correction officers and and some other
people who work at 24 7 facilities in an
attempt to retain that
staff and um
we I would
add this we performed a ministerial
function that is to say we carried the
paperwork to you yeah
who who got the who got the incentive
payments for example not a single person
who works for me
um was not necessarily our choice
um and that's a discussion in state
government and with people who allocate
arpa funding and whatnot
um I think that most of those agencies
it's a better question for the agency so
um I know that at one point commissioner
Sheehan before she left at dot because
there have been some there that was one
of the groups affected by incentive
payments particularly winter maintenance
um thought that it was
um
stabilizing their decline
of employees right which is a thing
right did I get more employees was I
going to anyway did I do have the same
number was I going to lose employees
it's what makes the analysis of it hard
and I think they would they would argue
that that particularly at that point in
time when other agencies were offering
incentives that they were relatively
successful in in keeping it but I don't
have data on that and those agencies
probably would okay I was just curious
if you had a number I know is a real
concern of the past year of fiscal uh on
burger that so we needed to do something
and
hopefully this would help minimize the
blow out and keep them in if I'm if I'm
honest and I'm seeking for myself here I
think the
the
state government has an uh easier time
recruiting when when labor markets are
loose and when the economy is bad and
has a harder time recruiting when the
economy is strong and the labor market
is really tight that that's been true
probably for 30 or 40 years and and I
think that's and I I don't want to say
to somebody wait for the next recession
we won't have a problem hiring yeah I
was hoping you weren't suggesting not at
all but um
um although there's a kernel of Truth
and that that silliness right that that
there is something about that
um over time you know uh
you know broadly speaking if you compare
CPI and and average wage
um you know our our selling point is
really but the benefit package but that
leave that aside you compare average
wage over time we have kept up in recent
years particularly because of the the
significant inflation
um of a kind that most of us don't
remember very well
um of recent years we've Fallen a bit
further behind I think the biggest
obstacle is that in some sectors outside
um
private employers have kept up better
with CPI than the state has the the and
apparently there's a tentative agreement
on a
um the wage increase it would be 10 in
the first year which is significant it
doesn't make up for the entirety of the
CPI loss but I think what it is is I
think that will have a much more
dramatic impact because it will it will
reduce the the gap between well you know
I'd like to start at 120 well we're
looking for somebody between 48 and 62.
and and you can't compete with that you
can compete with you know we're going to
pay 70 but there's work-life balance we
have terrific benefits it's a great
place to work and public service and
these kind of things and so I think
that's going to have a more dramatic
impact than than one-time bonuses I also
if I'm honest I worry about
I worry about what I I understand the
reason for doing a lot of bonuses the
last year or two and I and I get them I
think on a going forward basis I'm
always concerned about disparate
treatment of employees because anytime
you're you're particularly nice to one
group of people
there's a you've drawn a line and
there's a second group of people that
you're less nice to and feel like
oh why him what's wrong with me am I not
a valuable employee and you the answer
can't be yeah no we're just going to
take you for granted and I and there's
always that danger right where you're
you're trying to balance that like I
have an I have an issue here but I don't
want to
you know we couldn't give everyone a ten
thousand dollar retention bonus right
and so I guess I get that that's why we
didn't do it but there are a whole lot
of people who are going
well which where am I on the which side
of the line am I on and why and I think
that's always difficult
uh representative McGuire I believe has
a question
thank you Mr chairman to follow up on
what um our chairman asked
um on the classification system
is one of the categories the the
hazardousness of the conditions under
which the employee is working and
therefore something like a corrections
officer would be a number five and
somebody whose conference room ceiling
might fall on them as a number one or
something like that does that well I'll
start by saying we took down the ceiling
files that are falling so we've
corrected that I think it's important to
note
um and um and they never fell in
anyone's head
um the uh yes one of the one of the
criteria is work environment and so
they're um you know that that is a very
significant thing and and you know on
some level you know people are gonna
have to work outside
tonight and tomorrow that's a thing and
Hazard is it and it has to be absolutely
so we will received this particular
chart from Corrections and I don't know
if Mike can give you a copy or whatever
but it shows that the Corrections
Officers are the lowest paid of all the
groups of officers on this list and so
this is what was concerning so I was
wondering if your department could could
verify that this is a correct chart
um and or maybe there's other officers
that aren't listed or something to make
it look worse who knows but it's
something it's certainly something that
that we can take back and look at and
and if if you have a can I keep this
yeah or we can make a copy or either way
um and I can take back and look at it I
I do know that you know from on a broad
um look I know state troopers make more
than correction officers and I I uh
wouldn't surprise me to find the
correction officers are not among the
group two positions are not among the
top two or three highest paid but I
don't know all of the details and um or
the analysis that that leads to that so
but we can look it up and I can get you
some sort of answer about why
oh because some numbers inside the
classification system push state
troopers one way and correction officer
the other way is that well that so that
could happen at some point I mean if you
if you you know uh correction officers
and state police are different uh unions
and so different bargaining units and
some some things could change that I
would be surprised if the disparity was
over dramatic
um given that I think correction officer
raises have been significantly higher
than
um state trooper raises in recent years
but we may have started there I don't
know but let me uh again again let me
look into it and see
um kind of where things stand
um I just I have no expertise on whether
these numbers are good or bad but I mean
if I'm honest like Corrections gave them
to him
pretty sure they got them out of the
system somewhere all right let me let me
continue on this just slightly sure you
may remember years ago you and I talked
about
um supervision right because the one of
the categories that creates a
classification is whether somebody
supervised is a supervisor and we had
discovered that something like 60
percent of all positions or all
employees had a classification of
supervisor when most of them had no
direct reports at all has anything ever
been done about that I don't I I don't
think that uh so there are a couple
things there there's a there's a broad
Legend with some truth in it about oh
you know the way you get the way you get
more money in the system is to is to
become a supervisor and then they bump
you a labor grade and it's in and it
isn't true and and in in theory that
that shouldn't affect uh things your
position needn't be supervisory to be
more complicated and more demanding
and the fact that you supervise someone
is not in and of itself
a reason to to increase the the number
of points what happens is the rating
factors are assigned points
um and it increases that there I know
that there have been times when when uh
when that was true when there were
positions but I I don't think it is
today true to say that 60 of the people
um are supervisors in the system I don't
I don't know that but that's something I
could look up yeah let's let's and I
will get back to you
um and unrelated questions I would add
to that
um one of the I think there's an
awareness some members of the committee
will be more aware of this in some less
that we are undergoing
um
you know the governor's had a lot of
first everybody has had a lot of
frustration about the classification
system and and I said it was designed in
1950 and and I don't want to say no
changes have been made to it since 1950
but
frankly I read the 1950 handbook and
it's remarkably
um relevant today like much more so than
it should be
um we're making significant changes to
the to the system
um with lots of stakeholder groups
including unions including Commissioners
including employees and broader groups
to try to simplify the system make it
easier to understand make the uh rating
factors fewer and more flexible and to
include for example compensation like
today
today the system New Hampshire's
classification system many states you
may not under any circumstances take the
market compensation into account
so you evaluate a nurse for example and
you say based on job points and
complexity this is where they fall in
the system and it is it is therefore
labor grade 16. and somebody says to you
well yeah but you can't hire a nurse at
half of that or double that right and so
you should and no people don't look into
that system is meant to take that into
account become some uh more simpler
easier to understand for employees and
managers alike and to link to nationally
Norm standards the federal government
has data through um they have data
through onet and a classification set of
codes through something called sock
and the OC and sock stands for
classification or occupational codes and
I don't know what the S stands for but
the idea is to link to nationally known
standards and one of the goals of that
is to reduce judgment calls
and I think that would address some of
that as well okay now an unrelated
Factor um you said that one of the big
things your department does is health
insurance right does that include
municipalities at all or not no it does
not we provide a
we provide a health benefit for state
employees and a health benefit for State
retirees and and it is it's uh I would
hasten to say it's uh we're self-insured
so we're not buying an insurance policy
that's a change that was made roughly 20
years ago O2 I think 03 maybe when Craig
Benson was governor I don't remember
when that was anymore exactly
um so one of those years is when that
happened and so we administered the
program ourselves we have a third party
administrator but um the state is the uh
State of the State has the risk not to
ensure but it's just for state workers
not for municipalities too it would be
I'm going to throw this out there
because I've been discussion in the past
about well why don't you do everybody
it's not the business we're in and it's
not what we're set up to do and it would
dramatically change
how we operate what it costs and
probably what it costs to the state
because they're different risk pools and
all of that that goes along with that
probably
dude I I did testify in opposition to
bills but most ly because of the things
that Charlie's saying is uh we have 18
people to run the state health benefit
plan so we are talking about a different
magnitude
um and and complexities that I'm sure we
could figure out but they are
um sort of mind-boggling if you think
about it different collective bargaining
agreements for the State versus the
municipality the next one the next one
the next one different contract terms
with what well who's providing their
coverage today is it fully insured
self-insured what's that term so how do
you how do you put the puzzle together
is really kind of how we've discussed it
so just food for thought thank you
Cassie was director of risk and benefits
until I asked her to be Deputy
Commissioner a few years ago
because I think it I think it'd be uh
questions are actually much better
um for this I'm going to talk about
um
well let me let me do slide three why
you should care
I mean literally I wrote on the slide
why should you care
um
every agency in the state relies upon
the processes and approvals we do
um every agency in the state not some
not most but everybody and
um
we no matter how big or how small and we
treat everybody the same we don't have
one set of rules for HHS and a different
set of rules for the board of tax and
land appeals or anything like that and
it's it is a constant thing that we do
and it puts us in touch with with
um with every agency and with the
operations of every agency and the
challenges of the of the broad running
of state government
um
and and I wrote here at the state it's
policymakers and it's Auditors rely on
us to implement and support policies and
procedures to ensure the Integrity of
the budget the systems the laws and
rules of the state that sounds like a
mission statementy thing but if you
think about it at its most basic it is
what we do
um
uh people over here and people across
the street and including the one corner
office
um constantly have ideas and things that
they do and they usually pass in a
sheets of paper and and they need them
to be done and you need you need them to
know that you need to know that there's
not some agency going yeah I don't know
that was a stupid idea we're not doing
that that uh that we're actually doing
it it is spelled out actually in our
statute that um
it describes the role of the
commissioner as the state's Chief fiscal
and policy control officer and control
not in an old-fashioned like you know I
get a bull whip and a hat but um in in
internal audit controls and and we
monitor things we audit things and and
we make sure that that payments and
actions are taken in accordance with law
and you know fundamentally we are we are
we are a state of laws
um not of not of random people making
judgment calls and we're the people who
do that
We Do It
um frankly with significant staff
reductions if you if you look at budgets
uh over the last 10 years we've gone
down 41 positions we have and to give
you an idea we have about 305 uh
um full-time staff in in the budget and
and a couple hundred part-time staff
um a lot of them are Karen's Karen has
220-ish staff so
so right so like our biggest division
has 225 staff and I'm like so Karen will
be meeting with another division
director who's like yeah I've got 23.
and it's like she's we have slightly
different issues
um I want to uh hit one thing on on
slide four
um and we'll talk about this a lot when
we do our budget presentation because
there's some changes that that we're
making but
when I say that um we're we're two
agencies retiree health and then
everything else everything else being
the operating administrative Services
Department
um you can see that financially that's
almost literally true half and half
um
um we're gonna have a double counting
thing called Central facilities expense
where we're going to more accurately
account for facilities and you'll see
that when we do our budget presentation
I we have 30 or 40 priorities that we're
working on and actually in the process
with with all eight divisions and a
couple of other offices of doing that
strategic planning right now and I have
eight uh emails in my inbox from the
last two days because they were they're
meant to be to me this week
um but if you're looking at um page five
this is the Where Do We Go From Here
slide
I want to mention a couple of things one
is the cloud
the state enterprise system the State
Management computer management system
back in the day we had a we had a series
of computer systems a lot of them
actually started in the late 70s and
early 80s and what we typically did is
stop updating them at some point because
it's you know keeping them current and
so you know we're running you know it's
you know 2012 and we're running you know
with Windows 79 Word Perfect 5.1 you
know whatever and not those but we had a
system and we decided instead of
upgrading it we're going to home grow it
and at some point you run out of paper
clips and duct tape and and that
happened in in 2008 and and the state
moved to a new Erp it's it's run by a
company called infor we're at a stage
right now where the next major
um we do upgrades all the time we made a
decision state government policy to
upgrade not to not upgrade to keep keep
up to date um I'm sure there are cyber
security reasons for that too
um and we're at an inflection point
where the next upgrade is a big one in
part storage on the cloud people will
talk about the cloud instead of running
a bank of servers in a closet in a room
in the basement right because it's
cooler
um and uh and having like oh we have one
back up here you know the state state is
kept in in one spot on one side of the
river in another spot another another
side of the river but you know God
forbid all of Concord went down we're
just out of luck
um and you put it in the cloud and it's
where things are and it's probably you
know Amazon Cloud is probably where it
ends up but it's also a major update to
the to the system to the financials of
the system to the budget software the
the payroll software the purchasing
software the accounting software the HR
software I'm sure I left something out
but everything that we do that runs
every process that we have
that is a major thing we're actually
going to be at fiscal on
whichever Friday that is
um to um for the first 15 million
dollars of funding of a project that's
going to cost about 25 million total and
it's a significant upgrade that's going
to take
um well over a year
we hope to finish by the end of 2024
ballpark
um
if all goes well you won't know what
happened
that's our goal right nothing that you
just won't even know it happened
there'll be a lot of people who do you
know AP and AR and things like that
who'll be really happy
um
relatively happy
and everyone hates their Erp right but
but that's the goal um it's significant
it's dramatic and it and it's something
where we want to get to a point where
there aren't I.T pigs in the python
where every every six to 12 years you
have a giant pig you have to swallow in
terms of budgeting standpoint we're
we're trying to
um get to where instead of these giant
cat-backs periodically as a standard
operating aspect and that's what this is
procurement standardization is another
thing that I hope you won't notice
either
we the state has some
we need to get to a point where there's
one website you click a button and if
you sell teacups you can go and see
every teacup contractor every
opportunity you have to bid the state's
business what can I do I sell carpeting
who can I sell it to how can I sell it
right now there's we have a centralized
one but there are a lot of other ones
and we're working on standardizing that
and and creating a module called
strategic sourcing but as part of the
Erp that allows us to better track these
things and
some of this is the governor right the
governor like uh some of us the governor
some of it's the executive Council some
of it's the legislature at some point
everybody's come to me and said I I know
a guy who sells cups
we don't actually buy a lot of teacups I
I should come up with a better vacuum
cleaners and he wants to sell them to
the state where can he look and I don't
want to give him 25 places to go and for
God's sakes can it be something I can
understand and search and the answer to
that is well we're getting there but
we're getting better and and that's
something we're working on and uh the
way the way Dennis put it Dennis school
he put it to me is I think we're I think
our first iteration can be 80 of what we
need to do
and make an enormous difference almost
immediately and so so I think that's a
big thing
I think about purchasing every day
because I'd spend half my life signing
documents the other half in meetings but
signing documents and and you know
septic services and snow plows and snow
plow services and teacups and gasoline
and pick something and I'm like I have
more emails in my inbox about toilets
than anyone ever should
um and that's but it's something that we
do it's something that is very important
and that you don't think about but it's
the backbone of the state
um
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so
is there any opportunity on something
like that say diesel fuel where
cooperation with other states in New
England might gain some efficiency
we've looked into into that a little bit
I'm going to use road salt as an example
we bid we did a an actually a reverse
auction on road salt uh maybe three
years ago right before covet I think and
um or the state of emergency and um
we bid jointly with them they dropped
out halfway through because they'd saved
enough money
and um and so was it a good deal yeah
not bad was really good for Vermont
because they hadn't been in a while and
so they saved a ton of money
um we we got a good deal and we saved a
little bit of money and and it was good
for us so we try to do that whenever we
can and our in our purchasing staff
um is routinely in in contact with
actually teams has been great because
you don't have to have to worry about
going to a conference or something so
people can do that but you know what are
you guys doing what are you bidding
there's some national contracts through
an organization called naspo the P is
for purchasing National Association of
State
purchasing some things officers
um and so we've we've looked at a lot of
that
so sometimes there is sometimes there
isn't and so um
we'll talk to them the New Hampshire is
more aggressive than a lot of states are
in how we
um
part of this is the council process
right every contract has to go through
Council like of over 10 grand and in a
lot of States
um
and I know a guy once who did
Hardware in New Jersey and and I'm not
going to be overly specific about all of
this but
he had the and I have some details wrong
but I had the contract for 40 years
and
you know there are obligations on you at
Christmas to make sure everybody gets
what they want
and you just make sure that you know you
check in periodically with Bob and and
and you got to do a good job but Bob
likes you he's not going to bid the
contract because we want to do the
business with Fred
we don't do that we rebid
and and so there's some of that so some
um
strategic facility management well we've
we've spent a lot of time looking at
facilities
um Karen spends her life looking at
um and uh uh Karen started with ndas as
a state energy manager and so it's
actually a really good experience for
being for managing all of the facilities
and figuring them out because you're
looking you're looking you know broadly
speaking at everything and you have to
prioritize and triage and figure out
what what we can do
um we'll have some discussion in our
budget about a change we're making about
how we allocate facility costs around
the state where you know period in the
past we used to sort of try we we took
and use General Services we took the
highest paid employee and assigned them
to the biggest accounting unit
and the second highest paid employee and
assign them to the second highest
accounting unit regardless of where they
did their work and it was it was
administratively simpler
um and it approximated fairness in a
very approximative way and so now we're
gonna we're gonna track that more
efficiently with some things I mean you
know a utility bill is obviously
assigned to a building and people know
that most buildings are one accounting
unit and it's how we track how much
you know dra is an accounting unit right
and in their budget they have a facility
charge and that you know on some level
that that's how much it costs to collect
taxes
the cost of the facility they sit in is
part of that cost and then they pay us
and it's a it's a it's a double charge
in the budget but it's a it's not double
spend it just appears in two places
um and so we're trying to do that better
we're looking at some long-range
planning the state in infrastructure I
would describe it as aging but I think
that would have been accurate 30 years
ago and there's a different word to use
for now and somebody said to me
um six months ago
like when do you decide to tear down a
building
we don't because there are a lot of
buildings that you would in an ordinary
you might tear down but you know we keep
using and uh and uh because it's what we
have and we use what we have you know we
we're driving the the 69 Vega
um and just getting a new muffler on it
um even if it's starting to burn oil and
but we're trying to make some strategic
decisions on that and the
um this Committee in the past saw fit to
establish a maintenance fund where we
where we take a small surcharge on the
on the charges we we assess agencies I
think it's 75 dollars a square foot and
there's a cumulative fund that's meant
to to hit
um items that are not capital
they're not so big that it's a you know
a 500 000 Capital item and it's not so
small that it's regular maintenance you
know updating the elevators uh uh fire
extinguisher maintenance stuff like that
it's somewhere in between and we're
trying to use that strategically where
we hope to get to over the next two to
four years is a sense of
the long-term needs of every building on
a much more granular level our deferred
maintenance list the last time we did it
not because that's our deferred
maintenance but because we had an arpa
request the arpa committee or whatever
that was said can you send us a deferred
maintenance list and so so Karen had to
do it at some point she said to me how
much do you want on this
like do you want to and I said I said
don't go nuts but
um I said I want to give them about 250
to 300 million dollars so do that don't
do a billion because we
at some point it's gratuitous right you
don't track everything because you're
like we're gonna spend a million dollars
a year we're not going to have a list of
a billion we're gonna make sure we hit
the hit the big stuff
so we're trying to do that and then
trying to manage efficiencies with our
Operations Division of personnel is
making a lot of changes I mentioned the
classification system because I think
most agencies would find that a um a
choke point that they would like fixed
we looked at as always talk about
centralizing or decentralizing
operations
we decided to do something different
large agencies have large HR staffs
small agencies have no HR staff and
we've been experimenting with it with
what we call an hrsu a human resources
Service Unit
um oh I'm sorry support we change it to
support not service we're supporting
people
um and um
because if you you know just because you
work at HHS or safety doesn't mean you
should have better service than if you
happen to work at you know the board of
tax and land appeals not to pick on them
where they don't have an HR position so
it's very different
um so that's a model last thing I want
to mention is Paid Family and Medical
Leave This is a program that was in the
budget and it's an example of things I
talked before about staff reductions and
the Staffing I don't want to say issues
that we have but but we have a smaller
staff than we did six eight years ago
um when a significant priority is placed
upon us everyone working on this project
stopped doing
their other work
and and I'm going to use Cassie as an
example
um it's not like she wasn't doing
anything
right we had before she started working
on pfml I had this conversation with her
about about your goal for next year
needs to be to average a departure time
earlier than seven o'clock at night
um not that she was winning that battle
um but and then this gets placed upon us
and it and it and it it's crushing and
not it's not about this program the team
that's worked on it has done a really
good job and it's multiple agencies and
in taking an amorphous blob and turning
it into a program but
I would ask you that when you think of
something that's really good and
interesting and that you want to do when
you assign it to us because you think
that we do a great job and we have the
best people in the state working for us
which I firmly believe
I think all the best people in the state
work for admin services or or will soon
and
um
right
um and uh
no I was I I tried once
but it didn't work
um
um when you do that we're very happy to
to you know we're here to serve we are
we are administrators who implement the
policy choices that policy makers make
but I I just want to caution people that
um
the greatest resource that we don't have
is time
and and I just want everyone to be aware
of that and I I spend every day thinking
about the
time pressures on a lot of people that I
have and and how to how to mute them so
that they don't eventually burn on a
ball of flames and take a
a better paying job with worse benefits
somewhere else
but I I'm happy to talk to you about
anything that we do but I want you to
think of us as the people the people who
can help no matter what the question is
questions
representative brills
uh yes going back to the uh purchasing
unit you
do you use just everything is it
everything based just on the lowest cost
or do you also look for Value in the
things that you're purchasing it um so
we on on so I want to separate out
Commodities and services right so on
Commodities generally speaking as long
as you meet the spec the idea is that we
put a spec in and if you meet it lowest
price wins I don't on some level I don't
get to go I'm pretty sure that you know
WB Mason does a better job or whatever
and so we do that on we have rfps for
for things that are services or Services
combined with commodities and there's
typically a component where where we can
look at things like track record and
um
um and and and the you know the quality
and the ability and what they do
typically the financial component on
everything is the is the highest I
I can't imagine going to the executive
Council and defending a bid where the
finance portion is less than 50 percent
but I'm going to use as an example
um
the State Health this uh State third
party administrator contract on Health
Care
um it happens to be that the person that
the company has won the last couple bids
is lower Anthem and a lot lower but
um but there's a actually Cassie why
don't you talk a little bit about that
because I think it's a good example like
it's was it 50 percent
um what Charlie's saying is we develop
factors to uh evaluate a bid and cost is
one of those factors and we typically do
it at 50 percent
um sometimes a little higher and then
it's a we we set up sort of a sliding
scale so every percentage you're off
from the lowest bid you you lose a
certain amount of points and and it
tends to escalate
um we often ask ourselves the question
and we have in the health benefit plan
many times because
um quality of service is very very
important and would we would we ever go
to governor and council with a bid where
it wasn't the lowest bid because we were
concerned about quality and
um and we've been lucky quite frankly
that we haven't actually had to do that
um
I think it's a really important question
because sometimes quality of service can
be so frustrating we spend so much time
trying to correct the performance of a
vendor and
um and with little satisfaction and we
we kind of chuckle in-house because
um I I have a Playbook with some vendors
and it's um it's 12 reasons I I don't
like you okay and it's my agenda I pull
it out and I I force them to endure the
meeting where we go through what what it
is that are our concerns with your
performance and and lo and behold three
years later I can almost take the same
agenda out you know and at some point
that gets so frustrating for us as as
planned administrators for our members
who are the recipients of the service
um yet are I I actually think and I
think Charlie does too that Cost
Containment keeping costs down is one of
our biggest responsibilities so I I
can't give you a straight answer other
than to say it's really really important
factor and it's something we do consider
one question one exception I'll just add
there's a state law for the hiring of
Engineers Architects and surveyors and
it's I'm going to say it's 21 High 18
but I'm probably wrong I'm just
somewhere in 21i which establishes a
process when you're hiring think of a
consultant on a public works project and
you're hiring an engineering firm to
provide a specific set of services that
tends to be qualification based rather
than
represent Maguire
thank you yeah we're this committee is
struggling
um on something very similar to what you
just talked about there's a situation
with DOT where we have a choice between
the cheapest and the best right and and
uh you know there's three quarters of a
million dollars involved and you know we
may very well go with the best instead
of the cheapest on that one all right
but let me ask you this
um we're work how is the trend the
latest Trend to work from home affecting
State Personnel is it can we
um consolidate some of our office space
because there's more people working from
home
um
so I'm going to start by saying I'm at
one end of the spectrum I'm working from
home which is that I don't like it and
and I know I'm old and Luddite in my
Tendencies
um
born on me the other day the guy in the
elevator with me and uh who who looked
like he was about 80 going up to watch
the house session
um said I've never seen anybody with
penny loafers in there since I was a kid
and I'm like well they're not nickel
loafers and um but the uh so so I have
our some archaic thoughts I get that
um
so put that in in that most agencies are
not having people work from home
significant there are some people who
work four or five days a week from home
and and under the new standard you have
to work at least one day every two weeks
and and there are there are uh legal
reasons for that
um one day or two weeks in the office
um in our agency we we allow divisions
if they've so chosen to work one day a
week from home for some people that
works and for others for others it
doesn't I don't think Karen's team is
doing that for example
um certainly and certainly not the guys
who mow The Lawns
um
no but nobody is uh if I'm coming in
three days a week I still need a desk
if I'm coming in one day a week
I still wanna desk I don't know that you
need a desk uh my understanding is doit
has done significant experiments with
hoteling as it's called where which is
basically you know we're gonna who's
here what day you get you know pick an
available desk that that happens to be
there and I think they're looking at
sort of a three to one ratio
so today that's not affecting things I'm
hoping it will because we have some
space planning issues we're trying to
sort through with
I'm going to use an example you do any
renovation of a building and we're
probably going to do some work in the
annex fairly shortly
um I hope
um it becomes impossible you know uh how
about we get we fix this room while you
move next door it doesn't really work
that way got to move lots of people out
and around and we don't have a lot of
space to do it with in addition to that
so much of our space is so substandard
and I don't want to overemphasize that
it's it's not like three quarters of the
buildings are about to fall down
but I would say more than half the
buildings need significant remediation
of some kind and so that becomes a space
concern but it's not really reducing our
well
let me let me take the
the skirt off of it
um
according to the state law
in approximately 23 days it's going to
be necessary for a place called The John
F sonunu Youth Development Center or
whatever the actual acronym is
to close
and
there is significant legislation pending
that mostly in the finance committee I
guess right now
um
one is Senate bill one and another is a
bill that's before us
and we're faced with the conundrum of
having to do something about this
um because there are how many kids are
there now what 12 some 12 12 kids there
and we've visited that facility I
visited a few years ago with the
committee
and obviously something needs to be done
the question the question is not what
are you going to do but how soon are you
going to get rid of it
um
have you had any contact with anybody
who's been inquiring about uh what what
you what your thoughts might be about
which way to go where to go no never
mind about where to go I usually people
tell me where to go
um I spent an hour and a half
um this morning across the hall was
representative Edwards
um I think it's House Bill 49 and um as
you know he's very interested in this
um we have we have estimates that we've
provided to to well house finance at
this point
um and I and I think the Senate
president's office about what we think
things would cost
um we were close enough to a contract
we've selected an engineering firm that
we could do a contract anytime to build
um a new uh 18 bed facility 12 beds that
could Flex up to 18 which is from a
construction standpoint an 18 bed
facility
of about 25 000 square feet
um if we went to contract in in
immediately ish
um it's about a year of design work so
uh you know I think from today to you
know uh we could have bidable documents
by let's say March or April of next year
and then probably not two years but
um
a little more than 18 months to build a
new facility uh at a cost of something
like 21.5 million dollars I know that's
not the number that's in one of the
bills but um so I've had uh engineers
and Architects going over numbers over
the last uh last few weeks and so we
have good numbers on it we we've been
and we've I've spoken directly in the
last couple of days along with the
director of Public Works to um
speaker Senator president
um house finance
and somebody else but they were in the
room with all of those people so we have
a sense of what's going on and and what
I said is in terms of programming etc
etc
um you tell us what you want to build
um and and we can build it but if you
say an 18-bed facility of this sort this
is a sort of facility that's built
around the country right and we know we
have a good sense of what that costs and
and call it 21 and a half is a good
number
okay
thank you very much and thank you for
coming here uh all of you
um so I have just uh I guess
several questions as far as process and
and financing streams and things of that
nature so you have the legislative
branch and you have d-e-d-a-s and I come
from public works I was there for 10
years and so I'm really used to a
situation where you have a capital
project that comes through that process
and there's a lot of discussion with Ted
copper and and you know we're sort of
testing versus different theories and
now we have um a situation where we have
the sununu center we have the
legislative parking garage where it's
coming through the finance committee and
some of those
methodologies that I'm used to from
Public Works don't seem to
and so in a situation where you have a
legislative project a capital project I
guess I'm trying to understand the
interface between Das and the
legislature just in a sort of a generic
way
as far as process
it's a good question and so I'm gonna
you know depends on the project and all
that and I'm going to leave aside
Capital because you understand that it's
a very defined process
you picked two
projects that are weird right the
parking garage is weird and the synonym
Center is weird that in the in the
ordinary course of events
um things of this nature Construction
would be part of a capital budget it's a
process there's a capital budget
overview committee and long or which one
are you on your own capital budget
overview
oh she's on long range I think Ted's on
capital budget overview but so the
Committees that look at it and examine
everything
um
periodically the legislature will pass a
bill and lately there's a whole arpa
thing that's weird too which is similar
where it doesn't go through that process
but a bill will come somebody has an
idea somebody has an appropriation
in the capital budget there are a series
of steps to get to a number that's an
estimate based on decisions that have
been made and people have reviewed
often with legislation
um there's some fog of war that goes on
where different people are talking about
different things and there's a little
bit of a well I think somebody told me
that it would only cost 15 million to
build a and that's what I heard well
does that include does that include the
engineering well I thought so maybe it
doesn't and there's no sense of what the
all-in cost is and then a piece of
legislation gets passed and then there's
this rumor out there that becomes well I
thought that's what it was going to cost
and and and you know I know I think
Tuesday we'll talk about this a little
bit with the parking garage and
um
you know how many spaces is the parking
garage and it's like well I heard and
then it was you know 600 or 412 or 396
or 1004 and um and I know which one of
those my staff hopes because we would
like a few spaces and we're not going to
get any but um but there's all of that
and so what I try to do
so I said to division three this morning
I said I I can't tell you whether you
should move the Center Minnesota or not
I can't tell you what you should do but
what I can tell you is that if you want
to build a building that's 12 beds that
can Flex to 18.
which is a 25 000 square foot facility
of this nature according to modern
techniques this is how much it will cost
this is our estimate this is what Ted
and Tim have come up with and we feel
confident in that number and in this
timeline
at that point
if somebody says well what if it's six
it's not going to cost that much not the
question
if you want to know what 12-18 this is
the question you want six I'll come back
and answer that and so what happens
sometimes with
I mean I I have to think that that one
point the reason I created a capital
budget was to take things of this nature
where there's a there's a big estimate
right that has to go along with it
and say we want a different level of
scrutiny on it when you think about the
difference between what house Public
Works does and what house finance does
and and the
you know just the nature of the kind of
Investigation they do
in each case more thorough than what the
other one does but in different ways
right and so when some things are one
off in a piece of legislation it's
occasionally odd
but um our hope is that through enough
questioning and back and forth
um you know we try to make clear the
question that we're answering when we
give a number and sometimes that's not
relayed
you know the telephone game right and
well you know I tell you you tell him he
tells him and and pretty soon someone
said well I heard it's about 30 million
for four beds or two and a half million
a bit and you're like wait I don't think
we said that did we
and so
I don't have a good solution to that by
so just talking then about
um
legislative process project
the
the state how it gets very confusing for
us as we're trying to administer all
these things understanding who owns what
building and who's responsible for what
so like you guys own and operate the
State House
right the Legislative Office Building is
owned and operated by the Legislative
no so how does that work you you own
everything
um State owns everything I want to say
that up front and and from literally
from an accounting standpoint at one
point it was a
building being transferred from the
owned by
safety to the whatever it was and the
Comptroller is like doesn't matter we're
not booking an entry State still owns it
different agency controls it so there's
that typically I'll give an example up
on Walker when it was donated to the
state by
Upham or Walker I don't know which one
but one but but literally one of them I
know that much was accepted by the
department of administrative services
and that's who it was donated to
uh nobody lets us have any say we we fix
the boiler we do all of that kind of
stuff but um we can't book it right
that's you got to call Terry and um and
that's sort of how that works the
in almost every building
we own the building and dra is a tenant
of the building it's not really how we
approach it and with the legislature
it's much more so because
um
because you're more intimidating
and at some point your your people can
go you know this is this is the way it's
going to be and it it isn't it's a we
have a very collaborative relationship
and Karen's staff and the and and the
people who who have offices over here
who do some maintenance things
um work very well together but um let's
just say it's not a partnership of
equals and the way it is with a with a
department but you want to talk a little
bit about about how we
how we manage a building in cooperation
the way that our costs are budgeted and
that the agency that occupies that space
reimburses us for the cost that we spend
on a building so if it's a utility bill
we pay the electric bill and then each
quarter we we tell them what the
expenses were and they pay that back
um so and that's the way it happens in
most facilities other than some I think
like this one is generally funded and so
we have a bucket of money that we have
to to provide maintenance and care for
that building we do everything
um in collaboration with the folks that
occupy and use the building so certainly
we're going to pay the electric bill
every month but if it comes to like oh
well we really need carpet in these four
areas we'll work with you to say all
right well we can do this much this year
and we can do the rest next year what's
your priority what would you like to do
first and so that's kind of how we
approach things so they're they're like
Charlie said they're the states building
so we were there to get the work done
we're there to advise if we think you
know this might be a better idea than
that but in the end at the end of the
day we want to work with the people that
in all the rest of the buildings in
state government there is a there's a
there's a budgeted charge right the bill
collecting Karen talked about
there are two except three exceptions to
that
the Secretary of State for the space
they have in the state house but not the
space they have in the annex
corporations and securities receive
bills the governor's office we don't
send a bill to
knows where there's the capital budget
overview committee that's sort of set up
for capital projects that come through
the capital budget process but just
because something doesn't come through
the capital budget process it doesn't
mean it's not a capital
project right so if you have a capital
project that the state undertakes that's
not part of the capital budget process
what is the ongoing oversight that that
project gets that it would otherwise
if you understand what I'm saying yeah
um things are done regularly have an
oversight process and things that are
um
I could put a period there
we like to think that for example the
parking garage is going to be a project
where
Public Works will be involved and and
you know part of the the rsas in 21
either in the uh upper 70s and low 80s
involved capital projects and some of
the right rules and regulations around
them and are the roles we perform and
the oversight and meeting building codes
and um and energy codes and a renewable
energy component and all those sorts of
things
and so because of that there's that
oversight that legal oversight that
they're required to provide
um
because we're currently considered the
using agency administrative Services we
would do the normal things that we do
where we have our staff and Karen people
working for Karen who are looking and
they're going what are we doing what are
we considering and and the the the check
on us is that if we're going to have to
manage it long term we care a lot about
how it's built and and there's a concern
there with how it's built
um so those pieces are in it and and in
this particular case uh
the legislature my understanding is
um
is not going to be particularly hands
off
this project and so I would anticipate
lots and lots of questions like that but
it doesn't have to be and I'm going to
use an example the steps to the
legislature were rebuilt at some point
and that project was removed from the
executive branch budget and as a result
um
you know I used to get
um at least I get teased by the governor
right because he's got a he'd look out
his window and see it hmm yeah
exactly and I every time I came up I'm
like I got nothing to do with that and
neither does anybody else over here and
that's that and it's
and it was important for me to say that
because I was like I don't I don't know
what's going on I can't answer any
questions and so that can happen if a
project is of particular importance and
the legislature signs off on it being
removed from any oversight but that's
rare
so I'll have the governor call you
so fortunately the governor can't see
the rest of us from his window but
anyway
um
so does to follow up on Karen's Point
yes
we've heard and use the example well the
bed's going to cost a million dollars or
maybe I thought it was two million
dollars or whatever we've heard all each
parking space is going to cost thirty
thousand dollars and up to fifty
thousand dollars and my colleague to the
left said why should we pay fifty
thousand dollars for a parking space
when my car is worth fourteen thousand
or whatever
but the concern I have and I think
you'll see this next Tuesday so just
giving you a heads up
the division wants to see at least most
of us I believe oversight and we want to
see your involvement because as you said
it's going to be your problem after it's
built
we have 25 million dollars as you know
and we don't want to exceed that amount
but we don't want to get to a point that
oh that's only going to buy us 200
spaces
so I hope that you and representative
evil perhaps working together can come
up with some language
that you will have oversight so there'll
be discussion there'll be participation
whether it's a group of people or some
existing oversight group but we want you
involved and as the legislation is
written now there is no involvement
required so we want to make that kind of
clear that we don't want people looking
out of their window and saying wow 1.8
million dollars for stairs so that's
where we're going with this I want to
give you an opportunity in advance of
Tuesday to maybe sit down with
representative evil and others on the
division to come up with some language
so there is some clear Direction and
then we stay within 25 million and we
get the spaces we need not only for the
legislature but maybe some for you too
I um I I think it'd be great and I'd be
more than happy to and what we had said
um I had a meeting the other day with
the with the director of Public Works
and and with the speaker and assorted
other people
um including the operating officer for
the uh for the house for the legislature
um and um
talk to him about the the rough estimate
we have today why that rough estimate
was where it is what the what the
inflection points in that estimate are
and and one of the things I said is is I
will understand when a bill passes that
you're not putting down a down payment
that you're giving an appropriation
that's a budget and that we must do the
task you have commanded within that
budget and a garage is a little bit
easier to do that with because there are
and go up and down on spaces and and
there's some ability to that but I from
our standpoint
um this is not just true on property or
construction it's for an accounting and
it's true on Personnel
um we're happy to have oversight I said
to someone once who people are sometimes
nervous about going to I'm going to say
governor and Council will pick them and
I said I'm not nervous going to governor
and Council because I don't care what
question they ask because I know what we
did I know why we did it and all they're
going to ask is what did you do and why
did you do it and I have an answer to
that they may like it they may not like
it but I know that we made the best
decision we thought we should make at
the time and that we had and that it
wasn't capricious
because you and I had very good
discussions about the Steam Plant and
for those of you that don't know it it
was very important to Charlie to make
sure that the facility fit the community
and you go by it looks like it's been
there 100 years like Charlie said and I
think we want something that looks good
but also is
Falls within the budget guidelines of 25
million dollars and and again I'm
concerned because we don't have anything
even on a napkin about what the parking
space has cost and how many it does
really give us so I again I appreciate
you working with representative Ebel in
the next couple of days that come up
with something that gives us some
insurance and I can try to get you I can
try to get you all a better a better
napkin that would be great yeah I mean I
and I I don't mean that facetiously but
if you uh we gave a sheet and it's a
it's a page and it's it's you know 35
lines-ish that I gave to the uh house
finance Hub division three on um on why
we think an 18 bed facility would cost
21.6 million dollars or whatever the
numbers 21 point something and I think
we can get to that level of detail on a
on a garage difference is that we
haven't we haven't really started
talking to a consultant yet and we're on
the verge of Contracting so I don't
think we know anything
I don't think so because we really need
you know there's no question no matter
who you talk to that we need a new
garage you know we shouldn't have people
of any age walking up from stores or
running under hanging netting to catch
concrete that's falling so it's a
but we need to have it done I just want
to
um are you responsible for the netting
wait right that's us isn't it yeah okay
thank you yeah
representative hatch I believe has a
questions thanks Charlie so even though
this is out of order I mean
normally if this was done through the
capital budget there would be specs made
there would be uh State Engineers
involved prior to plans being drawn and
we're we're not using that model
um but I guess I the my concern is that
we're not using that model and we're
circumventing the normal process
we're building something that I think is
pretty damn major and and how we how
will we handle
that aspect of it um normally if in my
business I built buildings I would just
get a contractor I'd consult with an
engineer we'd come up with a plan and
rebuild it and that's kind of what we're
doing for this
going to outside resources do you see a
problem in doing that or do you think we
should back up
and and this was my delay up but utilize
the resources we have within the state
in terms of engineering and otherwise to
do this or does it make any I don't
think it makes any difference myself but
that's me
I think I I want to I want to hasten to
say that um
while the appropriation process is
slightly different that we are going to
use a normal process We There were
meetings a very long time ago when there
and when it wasn't clear whether there'd
be any money I wouldn't say in 2019
to select an architect when and I think
at the time there was talk of it being
um half garage half office and so we
went through we selected an architect
when when uh when there was discussion
at the end of last session to go forward
one of the things I asked is I said you
know we went through a process we we got
letters of uh qualifications we had we
had Ford firms come in an interview they
went through a whole lot of it's a lot
of work to do a presentation and we
picked somebody and I want to use that
person because I don't want to just say
oh we rolled that out and we're going to
pick you know somebody's not somebody's
friend I don't I mean that wouldn't
happen but somebody's going to go yeah I
know a guy we'll do it we don't ever do
I know a guy so we had a process we suck
with it that's the person we want to use
we've not contracted with them but we're
on the verge of it so what we would do
and again you know there's there's a
financial component to it obviously but
what we would do is what we would
normally do is as part of that
qualification based process we would
select in this case an architect uh the
company I think people know Scotland
partners and uh happens to be and the
people who the architect who designed
the Boiler House
that's not the only reason he got the
but it made me think he could probably
do a garage that would fit in
historically they would then do that
process there would be a lot of meetings
with both the legislature and without
admin services to discuss it and there
would be people
from from your side of the fence as part
of that process and particularly as the
as the biggest user and we would go
through that process and lots of updates
but um we could even we could even just
say capital budget overview can
has oversight of it it's something that
simple frankly right well
that's the question though like when you
when you said like I was in the speed 's
office that
that when I was working with speaker
sure and I was in a lot of those
meetings so
um so I remember all this but what I
don't remember so like that's the
question if somebody's hiring an
architect or a consultant or whatever
for a legislative process a pro a
project is it you who does the selecting
or ultimately the legislature that does
the selecting what happens with with
um every Public Works project is there's
a committee formed that does a set of
interviews and there's a there's a panel
in this case that panel in 2019 included
um
the director of Public Works the deputy
director of Public Works and included me
the city manager for Concord
um
somebody else from the legislature and I
don't remember it might have been David
alaconis
um uh Terry paff
and I'm sure there's somebody else who
I'm not thinking of but so it's a group
of people who then listen to all four
presentations and score them and uh in
the in the high score wins and so and
that happens to be what happened
um I don't know if it was everybody
everybody's First Choice it happened so
been mine although frankly there were
two or three that were all really good
and they all had parking Consultants
attached to them so
that's a good process and that contract
would have to go to government Council
so that's that's another
see in this case that probably wouldn't
happen
that's why we need you know some
language for oversight because it is a
legislative thing so really the governor
like he said looked out the window and
yeah well the the construct now just so
you're aware based on the bill that
passed last year with the original
design work the the 9 million or
whatever it was
um
the way this will work right now
um and I don't believe that the the the
garage Bill appropriation that you're
considering changes us is it will
function as a normal
as any normal capital budget Public
Works project does and it will go
through all of those things the one
exception of that is that because it's
not in the capital budget it's capital
budget oversight involved and and that's
easily rectified but but the process
will be just as
um you know does annex renovation or the
new roof on the
um on the on something at Spalding thank
you on Spalding for example it'll go
Mr Hoffman
thank you I just wanted to ask a quick
question does it matter
as far as this process goes whether the
appropriation in the bill is to the
legislative branch to administrative
services
yes
I didn't see that if it's appropriated
to the legislative branch there is an
ability at any point in the process for
legislative staff to um
decide to change the process without
oversight if it were appropriated to us
as I noticed uh in the 9.3 million
appropriation the design and Engineering
money went to das and not to the
legislative brand I don't want to speak
for people who aren't here but my
understanding at the time was that one
of the Senators and I forget his name
but he was the president
decided that um
that would lead to Greater oversight of
the process
if I could I'm just looking back at the
fiscal note and our memory Services
correctly that the appropriation is to
the legislative branch
so that would reduce our involvement
significantly and that's why I'd like
you to talk to
a good representative from
Sunapee right no no London New London
well close you represent just for the
record I I knew I knew that you
represent
I believe Mr chairman you were thinking
of Lake Sunapee yeah there you go I was
yeah yeah Lakeside
well that'd be
I think we're uh close to done uh
hopefully
anyone has any questions at any time by
the way and I'm we're always happy to
talk so
and
I don't have another meeting till four
how long you've been commissioner now
um
five and a half
July 2017. I remember we used to write
those conservative columns
it's a different uh I will note that
when my the last of those columns I
wrote
I discussed um how every career is not
like the one that preceded it
and that my current job does not lend
itself to having opinions I've been
watching I haven't watched the news in
seven years and it's a wonderful
wonderful thing
well again thanks so much we're lucky to
have you Charlie and your staff thank
you I'm happy to be here anytime and
okay